Guten morgen tim tim ich habe keine ahnung ich war nicht da.
Logbuch netzpolitik nummer drei hundertundachtundvierzig vom vierten juni zwanzig zwanzig es ist schon fast sommer oder ist schon sommer es fühlt sich dann schon ein bisschen an wie sommer und alle.
Alle zieht ins freie alle zieht in die freiheit alle müssen demonstrieren.
Ich glaube einundzwanzigster juni ist sommeranfang oder.
Ist ja eigentlich der spaß schon wieder vorbei dann werden die tage schon wieder dunkler da mag ich immer gar nicht dran denken.
Nicht genau wann sommer ist geht es immer so schwer absehbar die paar tage.
Ja wir befinden uns weiterhin in der isolation in der pandemien.
Und jetzt ist zu allem überfluss auch noch ganz schreckliche vorkommnisse in den usa.
Dazugekommen die dort jetzt ja tatsächlich zu.
Massiven gesellschaftlichen auseinandersetzung geführt haben in die der präsident auch noch,
sehr viel öl ins feuer gießt das ist also die dieses diese goldenen zwanziger tim die du uns im september im dezember zwanzig neunzehn versprochen hast die habe ich mir auch anders vorgestellt da hast du nicht geliefert.
Sie sind einfach anlaufschwierigkeiten ja auch einfach große dinge müssen entsprechend sich auch erstmal ein bisschen einen ruckeln.
Also du sagst jetzt.
Genau.
Kann man hoffen ich sehe das ich sehe das was in den usa gerade passiert tatsächlich.
Der mit mit absoluten unwohlsein das macht mich macht mir sehr große sorge.
Ich denke jetzt ist er wenigstens für den kontext haben ja gesagt wir wollen dass,
in unserer sendung zwischen zwei deutschen weißen männern nicht zum kernthema machen aber müssen wenigstens kurz erwähnen dass ein
bürger in den usa ermordet wurde es handelt sich mal wieder um einen dunkelhäutigen menschen und es tritt nun,
erneut zu tage der grassierende rassismus den wir.
Überall auf der welt haben nicht nur in den usa aber eben auch besonders in den usa unter.
Polizei in form von polizeigewalt in der benachteiligung von menschen anderer hautfarbe im in der ökonomischen teilhabe an der gesellschaftlichen teilhabe und so weiter.
Und tatsächlich ist das jetzt glaube ich seit sechs tagen dort wirklich bürgerkriegsähnliche zustände,
in einer absoluten zuspitzung der gewalt und was ich so wo wir wirklich sagt dass er regelmäßig dass wir bei donald trump das blut in den adern gefriert ist wie er diese situation.
Gezielt anheizt also keinerlei anstalten macht zur in richtung einer ja.
Beruhigung des konfliktes sondern spezifisch auf eine zu schärfung hinarbeitet ja höhepunkt diese aktion wo er erst im rosengarten des weißen hauses ein interview gibt.
Du hörst im hintergrund die granaten von der csu gasgranaten oder was auch immer da drin ist diese.
Wie heißen die denn tränengas genau drinnen gasgranaten.
Und denkst meine güte ne wenn du das jetzt irgendwie schaust denkst okay der der krieg ist vor dem weißen haus so ne.
Und was ich aber nachher rausstellt ist das waren,
trumps schergen die gerade eine friedliche demonstration ausreichen damit er danach mit einer bibel in der hand irgendwie auf die andere straßenseite gehen kann und sich ohne ein wort zu sagen mit seiner bibel vor den.
Vor eine kirche stellt die besondere historische bedeutung in washington hat wenn du das in.
Sagen wir mal in irgendeinem arabischen land gesehen hättest ne,
dann wäre das jetzt hier hier der dispo tf erklärt den heiligen krieg gegen das eigene volk so ungefähr ne und das ist das was da gerade passiert ist und das irre ist dass diese form von.
Darstellung die geht natürlich von einem großen teil der gesellschaft wahrscheinlich annähernd fünfzig prozent sofort durchschaut von den anderen fünfzig prozent der gesellschaft aber nicht und ich bin eigentlich immer davon ausgegangen dass.
Herrschende in demokratien,
sich wenigstens um die anderen fünfzig prozent scheren und sich und und so etwas nicht machen,
um vielleicht ihre eigene würde zu bewahren und um das land nicht zu spalten und das scheint aber das erklärte konkrete ziel dieses menschen zu sein und das ist wirklich.
Ja da fällt mir nichts mehr zu ein wieso oft das ist irre.
Teile und herrsche ne also er hat so nero zuzüge dir da entwickelt so ne also lass doch die die stadt brennen hauptsache dass es irgendwie gut für mich.
Einerseits natürlich kann man sagen okay totale eskalation und da war in gewisser hinsicht auch mitzurechnen andererseits auch sagen.
Der wird nervös ne also ich glaube der sieht auch sein ende auf auf sich zu rollen und wirft jetzt alles dagegen und da gibt's dann sozusagen wie er ohnehin in seinem leben nichts anderes als ihn
das ist ja ein ein totales ich monster,
das geht die ganze zeit nur um ihn und seinen klaren und alles andere ist ihm ehrlich gesagt ziemlich egal und wir werden sehen ob die amerikanische gesellschaft in der lage ist sich da ausreichend zur wehr zu setzen.
Denn.
So in teilen hat man ja gesehen dass also nicht nicht jede polizeitruppe an jedem ort geht diesen weg auch mit.
Aber gibt immer noch genug behält die sich da einfach in die erste reihe stellen lassen.
Was er jetzt inzwischen also was er bereits einsetzt ist ja an vielen orten der nationalgarde das ist.
Ich weiß jetzt eine deutsche entsprechung unbedingt so gibt ich glaube in deutschland werden dass die reservisten aber im prinzip sage ich mal so militär.
Angebundene gruppen ja die also nicht vollzeit militär sind sondern.
Was weiß ich regelmäßig ein paar wochen irgendwelche auffrischung trainings machen an der waffe um.
Theoretisch auch in einem kriegseinsatz eingesetzt werden zu können aber eben auch eher dann auch so im,
ja solche ich sag mal solche maßnahmen wie vielleicht bei der flut helfen oder bei einer naturkatastrophe helfen oder eben gegen das eigene volk.
Kämpfen durchführen es ist militäreinsatz im inneren ist das was da gerade schon passiert und das eben gegen größtenteils,
friedliche demonstrieren die die jetzt gezielt als gewalttätig diskreditiert werden sollen du hast ja auch irgendwelche nicht gekennzeichneten kämpfer truppen.
Die keine auskunft darüber geben wer sie sind.
Das fand ich am gruseligste muss ich sagen.
Du das heißt wo hast du sowas ne das wird dann irgendwie als russland die krim,
ja geschützt hat vor einer nato übernahme hattest du ja auch solche leute da rumrennen da wird das ganz dramatisch gesehen aber wenn das.
Bei bei uns passiert in den usa nee dann ist das irgendwie so völlig normal.
Wirklich irre was da passiert und es zeigt sich.
Also der rassismus in den usa aber auch überall sonst auf der welt der sich überall zeigt ja sei es nimmst du zugang zu bildung nimmst du einkommen nimmst du wo die menschen leben nimmst du die lebenserwartung egal was du nimmst überall auf der welt,
sind menschen dunkle hautfarbe stark benachteiligt und das.
Muss sich ändern und das ist in aller interesse dass sich das ändert und dieser diese wut.
Entfaltet sich da jetzt und zwar ja.
Mit sehr sehr viel anlass ist es eigentlich erstaunlich über wie viele jahrzehnte.
Wirklich also in nimmst du südafrika nimmst du nimmst du die usa nimmst du deutschland sich diese massive unterdrückung großer bevölkerungsteile.
So
Widerstandslos entfalten konnte und alle irgendwie so gemacht haben als wir das mit dem rassismus jetzt geklärt und das da das da mal behauptet dass mit dem rassismus wer jetzt geklärt kehrt man das ja halt um zu einer.
Das sind die aber jetzt selber schuld wenn die es nicht schaffen weil die so faul sind und nur kriminell und sonstige dinge ne das ist sehr sehr eckelig und da kann man nicht genug aufmerksamkeit,
drauf lenken aber.
Das machen gerade andere sehr viel besser und kompetenter als wir und ein satz den ich sehr häufig in letzter zeit.
Lese sinngemäß es ist ein privileg über rassismus zu lernen.
Statt rassismus täglich zu erfahren und das ist wirklich das entscheidende an dieser stelle wir haben jetzt erstmal einiges zu lernen.
Auf jeden fall meine die auseinandersetzung haben das hat natürlich auch noch eine zweite achse es geht ja auch um polizeigewalt und zwar,
wie man jetzt gesehen hat ja auch nicht nur gegen schwarze seinen rahmen dieser demonstration einfach auch gegen die bevölkerung also man man sieht einfach täglich
übergriffe auf friedliche demonstranten die so aus dem nichts einfach beschossen werden mit so blitzkrieg tränengas schlagstöcke
ein volles programm tritte.
Pressevertreter pressevertreter drinnen auch.
Kresse die einfach nur so festgenommen wird die einfach beschossen werden die einfach also es wird einfach alles über gebügelt und es ist auch relativ klar dass sehr viele polizei truppen da einfach vorgehen nach dem motto.
Wir müssen ja nicht gleich umbringen aber hauptsache,
hier mal die harte hand ja also es ist einfach so demonstration der stärke und da sind dann halt einfach auch regeln und gesetze und was sie eigentlich dürfen spielen irgendwo
keine rolle jetzt mag das in den usa auch teilweise sehr nachlässig nicht nur nachlässig kontrolliert zu sein sondern auch einfach nachlässig geregelt zu sein.
Also das ist sozusagen auch sehr viele kompetenzen haben und das natürlich auch ein problem,
und wie auch beim rassismus denke ich ist es aber auch angemessen da
einfach auch dass wir uns sagen die eigene nase fassen und sagen ja hier nicht nicht nur die doofe usa und so das ist halt einfach auch ein globales problem ist und wir haben das problem natürlich auch in deutschland wenn auch nicht in dieser dimension.
Und da verweise ich gerne nochmal auf unsere sendung logbuch netzpolitik zweihundertfünfundzwanzig dringende bitte.
Die schilderung zu dem g zwanzig gipfel in hamburg und da haben wir ja auch so eine.
Auf dem feedback so in den kommentaren den ganzen debatten dadrum gab es auch so viele leute die so gesagt haben ja nee kann ja alles gar nicht sein und hier deutschland alles wunderbar.
Obwohl es einfach alles auch so offensichtlich war und wir haben so ein medienzeug,
drumherum gehabt der das einfach auch die ganze zeit in dieselbe richtung gefragt hat ne also auch so dieses ja das sind ja alles plünderer.
Und die üben ja auch gewalt aus ja und hier die antifa ist ja voll gefährlich.
Ich meine dass das stand bei uns in den zeitungen dass das war das framing dieser ganzen zwanzig ereignisse in hamburg und das ist jetzt einfach exakt genau dasselbe was halt auch.
In teilen der medien steht und vor allem in den tweet von von donald trump der dann gleich mein soja hier antifa ist ja irgendwie auf der straße wir müssen jetzt hier mal antifaschismus verbieten weil das ist ja voll gegen faschismus.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher was er da vor hat mit diesem dass er jetzt patrick kredit antifaschisten zu einer.
Kriminell oder zu einer terroristischen organisation machen möchte ich bin mir nicht ganz klar was da das juristische ziel ist das könnte
ich habe erst vermutet dass es dabei darum geht irgendwie eine juristische grundlage für den einsatz des militärs im inneren zu haben wahrscheinlich geht es dem spinner aber wahrscheinlich auch einfach nur um ja tatsächlich halt
das was er da sagt mir das verbot von antifaschismus als terrorismus also es ist und vor allem es gibt ja keine organisation die sich antifa nennt ja das also in in dem sinne wie er das da meint dass man,
dass man jetzt sagen könnte wir verbieten die jetzt was weiß ich wie den ku-klux-klan oder so ne das ist hey.
Aber du hast recht mit den parallelen dass es dass es auf jeden fall ein ganz ganz offensichtlicher,
und auch ein altes altes playbook nachdem der verfahren wird.
Genau so und ich meine trumps kommentare sind halt auch klar also ich meine das mit der antifa das ist halt sind einfach wie es ja am laufenden meter macht,
immer solche träger signale in seine rechtsradikale basis so uns gibt ja da im viele so gruppen die so schläfer mäßig nur darauf warten irgendwelche triggerwand zu erhalten.
Gibt ja jetzt hier auch diesen neuen trend mit diesem bugalow nazis.
Auch wieder so ein vollkommen absurdes mehl aus dem internet was auf irgendeinem.
Uralten film basiert so wo dann irgendwie glow und
bungalow zusammengeworfen wird in die laufen jetzt alle mit so hawaii hemden rum und so mit hawaii muster und so weiter das ist dann sozusagen so diese diese erkennung und die sollte es sind halt auch schon vielfach in den demonstrationen gesehen worden.
Und fangen halt an gebäude einzuwerfen und so weiter also weiße tauchen auch einmal auf und und lösen das aus.
Was danach den schwarzen quasi vorgeworfen wird oder den friedlichen demonstranten und das das sind einfach auch solche maßnahmen die,
die gibt es nicht nur in den usa und da muss man einfach mal sehr genau drauf schauen also ich bitte alle nochmal doch buchner politik zweihundertfünfundzwanzig anzuhören,
ich glaube da kam das doch schon sehr gut rüber das ist auch durchaus an der zeit dass vielleicht auch in deutschland noch mal neu zu bewerten.
Und ich möchte an dieser stelle auch noch empfehlen eine.
Eine podcastserie die damit jetzt auf im ersten blick gar nicht so viel zu tun hat aber auf den zweiten blick denke ich sehr viel zeit über das was gerade mit der
mit den gesellschaften dieses planeten passiert und zwar heißt die rabbit hole
und wird veröffentlicht von der new york times und die handelt also von dem rabbit hol der in das sich,
indem sich menschen verlieren die ja sagen wir mal hetze fake informationen und komischen weltsichten,
primär im youtube kreis anheimfallen und kann ich nur kann ich nur empfehlen weil das,
eine wichtige metaperspektive ist zu dem was da gerade passiert wie gesagt behandelt diese gewaltausbrüchen auseinandersetzungen in den usa gar nicht primär aber gibt eine sehr.
Denke ich interessante.
Perspektive auf ja das mediale geschehen und das was da tatsächlich passiert ähnlich wie übrigens da suchen wir den link auch nochmal raus die folge mit frank unter dem alles zerfransten ja wo ja auch,
diese strategien zum zerstören demokratischer öffentlichkeiten.
Behandelt werden und ich denke bei strategien zum zerstören demokratischer öffentlichkeiten sind wir dann auch wirklich direkt beim.
Nächsten thema ich würde nämlich einmal noch ganz kurz ja hoffentlich zu ende erzählen wie es mit dieser droste.
Bild geschichte weiter gegangen ist also die als ich das letzte mal hier meine locker deaktiviert habe und versucht habe bild de aufzurufen lief die,
bild kampagne gegen trosten noch weiter.
Es gab jetzt dann so ja sagen wir mal komische schreiben beziehungsweise morddrohungen an karl lauterbach und christian trosten offenbar von einem gleichen absender am gleichen tag und.
Was hat trosten gemacht naja also.
Erstmal muss man noch glaube ich wiederholen es handelte sich um eine private studie die wissenschaftliche diskussion,
längst weitergegangen beziehungsweise wurde abgeschlossen was ich sehr bemerkenswert finde es ein,
einer der methodischen kritiker der studie der sich also im april gemeldet hat und gesagt hat pass mal auf das und das müsste anders analysieren ich habe hier einen vorschlag dessen
input haben die für so wertvoll befunden dass er jetzt koana tor dieser studie ist ja und das ist eine wissenschaftliche debatte ich glaube am freitag wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche.
Wurde dann auch die neue.
Eine neue version dieser studie als prima print veröffentlicht und diese studie wird jetzt eingereicht oder wurde jetzt eingereicht zum peer-review und wird dann irgendwann.
Erscheint also wie gesagt nochmal betonen,
diese diskussion die da jetzt stattfinden die finden ganz normal statt in der wissenschaftlichen community und zwar innerhalb der wissenschaftlichen community und nicht.
In der bildzeitung das war allerdings alexander colin nicht bekannt der ja auch nur,
ausnahmsweise ab und zu mal sich wissenschaftlich betätigt der dann nach dem ersten angriff der bild
auch noch aufgesprungen ist auf diesen zug ja nachdem also schon die kritik an der bild und in dieser ganzen kampagne ist das alles schon kanonischen war ja das alles bekannt war da hat dann kollege gesehen ach krass guck mal da kann ich öffentlichkeit bekommen.
Hat dann in deutschland funk interview morgens ja ich glaube das waren acht minuten interview,
noch setze gesagt wie jetzt wollte ich nicht noch eine viro logen streit anzetteln sie wissen ja wie herr trosten vorher mit herrn strick umgegangen ist also.
Taste schublade gibt in diesem interview dann auch noch zu,
erst durch bild von der sache erfahren hat und.
Beruft sich dann auf eine wissenschaftliche debatte wo man wirklich sagen muss der weiß also ganz offensichtlich nicht wie man.
So eine wissenschaftliche debatte führt nämlich im fach,
in der fachgruppe und nicht in der bild-zeitung und fordert dann auch noch trosten solle die vor veröffentlichte studie zurückziehen.
Sagte nämlich es ist ist nicht nachvollziehbar warum dorsten die nicht zurückzieht,
es ist ganz eine vor veröffentlichung nicht zurückziehen ja ist ja noch nicht mal veröffentlicht naja außerdem ist rost natürlich strikt genau nicht in den rücken gefallen sondern hat nur gesagt naja ich kann die studie nicht beurteilen weil sie nicht veröffentlicht ist.
Und strick ist ganz einfach ein opfer von kai diekmann nichts weiter hat einfach den falschen leuten vertraut und sicherlich auch daraus gelernt also ja man,
ich bin beeindruckt wie der christian droste hier.
Souverän und seriös durch wildes gewässer gegengesteuert ist ja bitte wunderschön,
feststellung wie ich wusste bis gestern nicht mehr julian reichelt ist und in meinem leben kommt die bildzeitung nicht vor auch das übrigens ein großes privileg.
Ich muss nochmal was zu dem kurz anmerken weil er ja in diesem tagesspiegel artikel dann auch mit seinem kern zitat.
Aufgefallen ist und genau das hat der tagesspiegel aber angepasst und uns da so eine zeiteinteilung reingebracht was der schärfe dann schon mal ein bisschen was sieht ich habe auch nochmal nach gehört was er selber jetzt in seinem eigenen podcast dazu gesagt hat.
Es ist ja nicht so dass er jetzt nur auf diese,
kritik nummer in puncto statistik draufgehauen hätte sondern auch was die viro logischen,
testmethoden betrifft und das ist ja auch etwas was jetzt in der neufassung der studie auch tatsächlich neu aufgeschlüsselt worden ist also das da mit unterschiedlichen test werkzeugen gearbeitet wurde und es
dass es sozusagen nicht einem in einer in einer darstellung zusammengefasst ist sondern dass es eben
je nachdem womit da getestet und ich kenn mich damit details überhaupt nicht auch nur im ansatz aus aber offensichtlich gibt es da zwei unterschiedliche labor die zum einsatz kamen und in der neufassung ist das halt auch entsprechend.
Aufgeschlüsselt also ich denke das sollte man auch nicht zu hoch hängen.
Gut dann nehmen wir stattdessen dass deutschland funky interview von herrn keko leer ja wo er gefragt wird ist die studie von professor trosten ihrer einschätzung nach zu retten er antwortet nee,
so wie sie so dasteht kann man sie nicht retten und sagt weiter
christian droste behauptet trotz all der kritik die da im raum steht immer und überall die ergebnisse sein trotzdem richtig
ja und was kommt raus die ergebnisse sind richtig ein ergebnissen hat sich nichts geändert ja und jetzt stellt er sich irgendwie groß da als sei der virus logen streit beigelegt und er hätte in irgendeiner form recht bekommen nein,
das ist einfach nicht der fall also sorry also.
Nein der typ geht überhaupt nicht sorry ich finde den unhaltbar und ich finde muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen der
wird in seinem interview auch darauf angesprochen dass er ja nicht mehr forschung tätig ist und sagt jetzt ja er hätte jetzt hier eine einen institut zu leiten oder so ja und ich habe auf twitter dann mal gesagt hier ein professor
der über jahre nicht publiziert ist eine verschwendung ja wir unterhalten diese professoren,
aus öffentlichen mitteln damit sie die wissenschaft voranbringen in,
forschung und lehre wenn die sich nur auf die lehre konzentrieren ja dann können wir besser andere leute nehmen die wir billiger bekommen,
ein professor der nicht forscht ist verschwendung von geld forschen und veröffentlichen ist
seine aufgabe dann haben haben sich viele leute bei mir gemeldet gesagt ja aber diese dieses publish parish und die veröffentlichung und so weiter das ist ja auch irgendwie eine komische sache jemand der sich nur aus veröffentlichen konzentriert ist ja auch kein.
Kein idealer beitrag zur forschung dass mag sehr wohl sein allerdings wird dabei oft vergessen dass die community sehr wohl korrektur,
faktoren für bullshit veröffentlichungen und ernstzunehmende veröffentlichungen hat ja geht nämlich ganz einfach nach dem impact- faktor des journals wo du veröffentlichst dass der erste punkt es ist sehr in der city community gar keine frage wer
ernstzunehmender forscher ist oder eine ernste forscherin und wer irgendwo im in in der bild-zeitung publiziert.
Und zweitens gerade weil aber es so billige möglichkeiten gibt,
auch bullshit publizieren ist umso unverständlicher dass keko leg noch nicht einmal das macht insbesondere als institutsleiter wenn du dich institut seid habt auch trosten dorsten ist übrigens der letzte genannte autor in dieser studie
ja
zumindest in diesem print wenn man sich da die autoren liste anschaut steht als allerletztes christian droste ich weiß nicht ob das in der veröffentlichung dann anders ist das kann ich nicht sagen aber üblicherweise ist die veröffentlichungsprozess
so dass selbstverständlich der.
Doktor vater oder institutsleiter oder lehrstuhl inhaber oder lehrstuhl inhaberin
in den publikationen seiner eleven ja mit erwähnt wird weil sie wurden ja durch diese person betreut
und das wäre quasi der teil der ausbildung der lehre das heißt wenn du einmal in einer position bist wie so ein keko lee da musst du dir echt mühe geben
nicht wenigstens aus versehen irgendwo nochmal deinen namen mit dahin schreiben zu können das ist wirklich.
Das ist da da musst du dir echt mühe geben ja und wenn der jetzt irgendwo anders publiziert was er nämlich dann auch hier im deutschlandfunk sagt er würde ja dann irgendwelche drittmittel studiert oder sowas machen ja
gutachten für staaten und dax-unternehmen dann möge er bitte,
seinen posten als professor räumen und gutachter für staaten und dax-unternehmen werden aber da braucht er keine professoren
gehälter einzustreichen wenn er sich als professor nicht an der wissenschaftlichen auseinandersetzung,
beteiligt und kein neues wissen schafft sorry können wir uns nicht leisten gibt's genug von da ist er jetzt nur ein beispiel ja die die universitäten sind.
Voll leider von irgendwelchen menschen die sich dann,
in einem lehrstuhl nämlich zur ruhe setzen ja und den lehrstuhl mit einem lehnstuhl verwechseln und das ist ein großes problem was wir in der deutschen universitätslandkreis haben und auch bekämpfen müssen.
Möchte ich tatsächlich so nochmal in aller schärfe sagen.
Ja in aller schärfe also ich weiß nicht sieht es nicht ganz so nicht ganz so schlimm weil ich glaube das lässt sich jetzt auch nicht so ohne weiteres vergleichen was was er da macht und was trotzdem
da macht man dorsten ist halt ganz klar grundlagenforschung das ist nicht sondern er ist halt mehr im im bereich der pandemien
bekämpfung an sich so und das ist halt einfach.
Wir haben eine pandemien gerade.
Ja genau da da ist er ja auch sozusagen der panik planung ist ja auch mit beteiligt und da war er.
Also ich sehe ich sehe von diesem chicorée wirklich keinen beitrag sorry muss ich wirklich sagen.
Weil du dir nicht siehst heißt ja nicht dass es den nicht gibt so also das.
Der ist ja auch in der ebola epidemie hatte zur panik planung beigetragen das kam dann auch zum einsatz das war ja auch alles erfolgreich also mir fällt es einfach schwer da jetzt so die keule rauszuholen und zu sagen
nur weil du jetzt hier gewagt hast den trosten zu kritisieren bis zum schlechter mensch das ist.
Das sag ich nicht ich sage ich sage spezifisch weil er sich zum zug fährt einer bild kampagne gegen eine person macht ja wo jeder jeder,
beteiligte virolent und jeder fachkollegen und jede fachkollegen sich weit sofort mit spitzen fingern entfernt hat hat der mann sich die ärmel hochgekrempelt
so und das ist also das ist nicht nicht anzuerkennen ja tut mir leid.
Ja gut aber gefeiert werden dann halt so zeigen ja und die die kritiker dieses papier sind dann halt auch alles nur noch kritiker aus dem ausland weil sie sich sozusagen gar nicht mehr trauen es mal aufzumachen irgendwie auch nicht optimal ne.
Nein das ist unsinn die kritiker dieses papieres sagen jetzt dass sie also erstens jede wissenschaftliche veröffentlichungen.
Wird kritisiert und diskutiert das ist teil,
das muss geschehen keine einzige stunde in der letzten sendung auch schon erzählt keine einzige studie kann so etwas wie die reine wahrheit veröffentlichen sie nimmt einen ausschnitt eine,
stichprobe aus der realität und versucht diese stichprobe aus der realität hinsichtlich gewisser fragen zu interpretieren und die stichprobe aus der realität kann in ihrer erhebung probleme haben und die stichproben
die stichprobe aus der realität kann in ihrer interpretation probleme haben und deswegen diskutiert man das.
Ja gut aber jetzt hat er das könnte genau das getan was ist dann so so schlimm daran.
In der bild-zeitung,
so und da da gehört's einfach nicht hin das habe ich letztes mal schon gesagt und da da gehört eine solche debatte nicht hin er hat sich genau das was die bild getan hat nämlich eine diskussion unter wissenschaftlern und wissenschaftlerinnen die
zielgerichtet war und zu einer verbesserung des papers geführt haben,
die hat die bildzeitung in eine öffentlichkeit gezogen und zu einem angriff auf einen forscher,
genutzt und keko lee hat sich dann daran beteiligt wie gesagt er sagt spezifisch ja dass er überhaupt erst durch die bild davon erfahren hat,
ja und vorher nicht.
Hat sich nicht mit dieser studie auseinandergesetzt weil er sich an dieser diskussion nicht beteiligt hat erst als die bild ihn dann damit angegriffen hat hat er gesagt akut das aber interessant damit setze ich mich jetzt auch mal auseinander.
Sorry ich sehe da keinen beitrag.
Aber er hat jetzt nicht in der bild ein interview gegeben.
Das kann ich dir noch nicht mal genau sagen wahrscheinlich schon.
Also davon weiß ich jetzt.
Corona krise professor kekilli kritisiert professor trosten streit der virus großer titel in der bild kann ich leider nicht lesen weil ich mit meinen aktuellen browser einstellung.
Ja gut aber wenn was die ja die bild hat auch von allen anderen die da kritisiert haben behauptet dass auf eine art und weise behauptet obwohl sie nie mit denen geredet hat also das.
Kollege sagt hat zitiere ich doch gerade also sorry.
Und zwar im deutschlandfunk wo ich mich auch frage wieso wieso warum fragen sie den und nicht mich ich habe genau so viel dazu geforscht.
Ja gut aber wenn wenn er sagt dass er das aus der bild erfahren hat ist es ja nicht er hat der bild ein interview gegeben.
Nein aber nein das ist ja korrekt das ist richtig aber er hat sehr offensichtlich erkannt dass ich hier eine möglichkeit für ihn bietet sich öffentlich einzubringen,
mit kritik an einem kollegen an einer stelle wo die weder im tagesspiegel noch in der bild-zeitung diskutiert gehört und während alle anderen fachkollegen sich
aus dieser sache rausgehalten haben und kritik an der medialen aufbereitung einer wissenschaftlichen diskussion geübt haben da als.
In dieser situation hat er sich überhaupt erst eingemischt.
Und zwar nicht bei der bild aber im tagesspiegel und im deutschlandfunk hat er letztendlich in das horn der bildzeitung geblasen,
tut mir leid.
Also naja mir fällt es schwer mich da so da drüber aufzuregen ehrlich zu sein.
Ich werde gerade erst waren wo ich mich gleich noch alles aufregt.
Ja das erscheint mir auch ein bisschen mehr fleisch zu haben womit machen wir denn weiter.
Ja also große großes hallo risa hat mal wieder ein video veröffentlicht wenn ich mich nicht täusche am was am sonntagabend ja pfingstsonntag oder pfingstsamstag einer dieser.
Lieblingssong tag war das glaube ich und zwar in mit einem mit einer medienkritik.
Einstündiges video sehenswert und wichtig und ich denke so die stunde ist auf jeden fall für alle.
Gut investiert da wird eine
sehr solide medienkritik mit vielen beispielen formuliert und geäußert er fängt im prinzip an mit diesen verschwörungstheorien tasten und zeigt dann weiter wie bestimmte,
praktiken die in den medien,
gang und gäbe sind wasser auf den mühlen dieser verschwörungsmythen tasten sind das macht er sehr gut und sehr ordentlich wie immer mit tausend quellen belegt und so weiter der einzige punkt den ich da noch
anmerken würde ist er beschränkt sich auf das handwerk ja und,
behandelt dann jetzt für falsch darstellung und so auch nur beispiele über ihn selbst und kratzt da in meinen augen so ein bisschen nur an der oberfläche einer medienkritik denn die.
Also neben den handwerklichen mängeln die er aus also dir sehr genau behandelt und.
Ja auch mit vielen beispielen unterfüttert liegt nämlich die eigentliche macht der medien in der themenauswahl also was wird nicht berichtet und dann erste frage was wird wie berichtet,
darüber hat er noch hat er hätte er noch mehr sprechen können aber wie gesagt,
dieses video ist sehr gut und sehr wichtig und sollte sehr viele,
sehr viel verbreitung finden interessanterweise das zeichnete sich auch schon abwertest wie gesagt ich glaube am sonntag veröffentlicht und da ja pfingstmontag keine zeitung erschienen ist ist die nächste bild am.
Dienstag denke ich dann mal erschienen und
am dienstag hatte das video dann bereits mehr als eins komma drei millionen views das ist deshalb interessant weil das die gesamte der bild-zeitung ist jetzt die bildzeitung behauptet ja eine bild von vier leuten gelesen würde
böse zungen behaupten der größere teil dieser zeitung landet einfach in der tonne oder wurde zu korona zeiten dann eben als ersatz für ein wichtiges.
Aber leider häufig ausverkauftes produkt genutzt auf jeden fall kann man klar sagen der hat eine große reichweite reichweite inzwischen mit diesem video als diese zeitung,
das hat auch gollum reichelt natürlich sofort geärgert und er hat sich dann zum horst gemacht indem er unmittelbar auf dieses video mit einem twitter ausbruch reagierte und,
darin auch sehr offenbar dass er offenbar das video überhaupt nicht gesehen hat ja sie hat ihn quasi schon
angegriffen und beschimpft in einem tweet storm der eines ja eines achtzehnjährigen nicht würdig gewesen wäre bevor er sich überhaupt das video angeschaut hat.
Und man sieht eben immer,
dem julian reichelt dem gefehlt ein dem fehlt einfach so eine gewisse reife die hat er die bringt ja nicht auf ja für so eine so eine auseinandersetzung.
Und ja auch irgendwie so einen umgang ja ich meine der hat doch irgendwie so ein posting artikel da vertritt hat ne und da hat der postet einfach den artikel geändert und hat,
wie gesagt so schimpansen sind sich einig die bildzeitung ist irgendwie nicht zu gebrauchen und.
Auch zum kacken nur widerwillig verwendet oder sowas ne oder beim kacken nur widerwillig gelesen irgendwie sowas haben die daraus gemacht ja und der voll.
Der hat ja wahrscheinlich bis heute nicht gemerkt der freut sich nur dass er die ganze zeit relativität wird hat diese auch nicht gelöscht oder so ne.
Er ist interessanter teil auch der operation security an der stelle ne also dadurch dass man eben ein ein ein tweet quoten.
Der dann ja dann in der timeline eingeblendet wird dann ist es tatsächlich so dass nicht die erste vision davon zusammengefasst wird sondern so diese preview die dann da erscheint also der
und das bild das kann tatsächlich laufend aktualisiert werden
so dass eben dieser artikel dann permanent seine gestalt geändert hat ohne dass der retweet nochmal wiederholt werden musste gewisser hinsicht auch ein problem ne also man kann halt irgendwas
zitieren und dann ändert sich der content vollständig und schwierig.
Postet berichtete darüber wie ein tweet von bildchen julian reichelt einmal viele tausend likes bekam das ist der endgültige beweis war der.
Ja ich hab das video von riesa auch gesehen ich fand es auch.
Gut also was mich am meisten daran freut eigentlich ist dass mal unsere wahrnehmung der super politischen youtuber szene dadurch natürlich.
Kratzer bekommt und das ist sehr wohl eben ist ja auch klar wir hatten ja auch den reich anders schon bei uns auf der bühne bei logbuch netzpolitik nummer was war das hundertfünfzig.
Zweihundert und das.
Gibt es halt auch das auch gut so und das zeigt eben ein gewisser hinsicht dass wir auch in der nächsten generation auch politisch denkende menschen haben wie sollte es auch anders sein und bin gespannt was da.
Noch bei rauskommt auf jeden fall interessant und das hat mir letztes mal auch die bild-zeitung hat schwierigkeiten.
Ihren ihr business durchzuziehen.
Ich sag nicht die fallen schon vom thron oder so aber da wird auf jeden fall ordentlich gewackelt am sockel und das das finde ich doch ganz gut und das sollte auch weiterhin so sein.
Also er er benennt auch andere übrigens ich glaube der einzige journalistin er namentlich benennt ist jasper von altenburg.
Dein freund.
Zurecht ja der halt auch eine reihe an falsch behauptungen einfach nur
nachweisbaren falsch behauptungen über riesa getätigt hat und zwar wiederholt also es ist ein intensivtäter und
jetzt möchte ich an diesem medienkritik von riesa anschließen
indem ich mal zwei beispiele die ebenfalls seit der letzten sendung nur mal mich ereilt haben kurz zum besten geben.
Gleich zwei.
Ja und zwar ist das erste ein youtube beispiel es gibt eine sendung oder ein kanal auf youtube mit dem namen valulis daily den ich bis gestern abend nicht kannte,
der aber ich habe mir die videos mal angeschaut das ist so eine pointierte.
Kritiker ja.
Ja pointierte sendung könnte man also wahrscheinlich so ich würde vermuten so ein bisschen nach schon oliver,
strebend oder so ne in diese richtung also sitzt sitzt ein,
philipp julis heißt er sitzt da und kommentiert geschehen der hatte zum beispiel auch das dieses risiko video und die reaktionen darauf behandelt und in der letzten folge.
Oder in der aktuellen folge von gestern diskutierten würde dort behandelt eine demonstration die am wann war das denn am sonntag.
In berlin stattgefunden hat und zu der aufgerufen wurde von einer gruppierung mit dem namen rebellion der träumer.
Die sich aus dem berliner club kontext zusammensetzt und
folgende forderungen aufgestellt hat erstens finanziell finanzielle hilfen für nicht staatliche kulturinstitutionen wie clubs und festivals die ja jetzt gerade massiv unter dieser corona krise und den einschränkungen leiden.
Finanzielle gleichstellung von solo selbstständigen künstlerinnen mit kurzen arbeitenden solange das konzert verbot besteht auch denke ich eine
sehr wichtige forderung weil eben gerade kulturarbeit und kalt kulturarbeit darin gerade einfach vollständig das einkommen weg,
und dann noch eine eher allgemeine folgerung forderungen solidarität mit den schwächsten in unserer gesellschaft da geht's also dann so in diesem
wie kontext ja also alles denke ich ordentliche forderungen.
Die man so auch unterstützen kann und jetzt haben sie sich überlegt wie sie ihre demonstration machen und zwar haben sie sich da boote,
haben sie sich überlegt wir machen das mit einem boot oder mit booten auf dem kanal auf dem landweg kanal in berlin.
Und haben da eine anlage auf das boot geschafft und oder auf ihre boote geschafft die irgendwie mit transparenten beengt und sind dann halt den landwehr kanal lang gefahren wer nicht in berlin wohnt das sind relativ beschaulicher kanal der an der stelle wurde jetzt da
wo das ganze stattgefunden hat quasi zwischen kreuzberg und neukölln verläuft ja und,
ja diese
das ganze war ja muss man einfach sagen eine eine relativ große party mit sehr sehr vielen leuten die dann so in gummipuppen in der nähe dieses bootes waren die
mindestabstand regeln wurden in weiten teilen der teilnehmerinnen dann doch recht großzügig das heißt also sehr,
eingeschränkt wahrgenommen.
Und es gab dann auch ganz sehr große menschenansammlung am rand und so wenn ich das richtig verstehe muss das dann irgendwann auch aufgelöst werden.
So das schon mal macht schon mal nicht den besten eindruck jetzt haben die dummerweise ihre demo ausgerechnet vom urban krankenhaus.
Positioniert das dass ein krankenhaus in,
auf der einen seite des landwehr kanals also denke das ist schon neukölln könnte auch schon kreuzberg sein weiß ich nicht genau auf jeden fall im urbanen vor dem urban krankenhaus befindet sich eine große wiese da waren dann natürlich auch viele teilnehmende dieser demonstration.
Quasi vor dem krankenhaus und die haben da ihre corona party vor dem krankenhaus gefeiert wo jetzt
potentiell vielleicht auch die ein oder andere corvette erkrankte person drin sein könnte oder drin gewesen sein könnte kann ich gar nicht genau beurteilen
zur krönung des ganzen hing an einem boot dann noch ein sehr großes transparent mit der aufschrift brav also inklusive dem rechtschreibfehler,
und auch das kannst du natürlich nur bedingt.
Vor einem krankenhaus aufhängen bei einer korona demo auch da gab es natürlich dann kritik dass das natürlich sehr.
Sehr skurril wirkt wenn du in in den usa im prinzip ein wichtigen kampf der sozialen gerechtigkeit hast und übrigens auch zum gleichen zeitpunkt wie diese.
Rebellion der träumer party,
luftlinie würde ich jetzt schätzen ein kilometer maximal nämlich am hermann platz eine black-lives-matter veranstaltung stattgefunden hat ja also das heißt die haben,
die waren mit ihrer party auch noch quasi konkurrenz zu dem zu dem black-lives-matter protesten das ist sehr
ungünstig verlaufen und das haben glaube ich haben die veranstalterin auch selber so benannt dass das eben nicht so dass ihn das aus den händen aus dem ruder gelaufen ist und so nicht beabsichtigt war und dass sie,
selber jetzt nicht zufrieden sind mit dem verlauf.
Also bei manchen details kann man ihn vorwurf machen beim manchen
muss ich auch sagen kann man auch ein bisschen nachsicht walten lassen dass man den probanden krankenhaus war auf jeden fall.
Gedankenlos also das also ich glaube nicht dass sie das gemacht haben um vor dem krankenhaus zu sein ja auf gar keinen fall sondern wenn man sich einfach mal das kanalsystem anschaut
da ist platz da geht der kanal in die,
da geht der kanal in die breite das wird der ursprung des gedankens gewesen sein ja da fehlte dann sozusagen noch der nachsatz so wir sind beim krankenhaus also es wird auch nicht so dass jetzt niemand wüsste dass da ein krankenhaus ist weil das
trank da groß vor diesem bereich ja des dominiert diesen diesen ort einfach und so nennt man diesen ort auch also jeder.
Genau so nennt man auch diese wiese wir treffen uns am urban.
Genau also das,
das ist klar alle alles noch kreuzberg nicht nicht neukölln was jetzt so diese abstandsregelung betrifft und so naja okay gut jetzt weiß ich nicht wer da mit wem in welchem boot war pipapo das ist irgendwie alles draußen ich finde das ist dann irgendwie eine eine nicky,
das sind parallel jetzt so eine black-lives-matter demo war ja okay gut das wusste man eine woche bevor er wahrscheinlich aber auch noch nicht dass er ist gerade unruhen in usa,
brechen ja und da durfte das alles schon geplant gewesen sein also dann zu sagen so ja ihr müsst jetzt komplett eure demo einstellen
weil jetzt ist gerade noch was anderes wo wir mal eben von nix auf knapp auch noch eine party gestartet haben sich dann auch ein bisschen schwach aber in der summe.
Ja
Ich muss ja auch noch noch hinzufügen auch die kritik an diesem plakat geht natürlich nur so weit dass das halt eine jane ungünstiges bild ist,
aber grundsätzlich denke ich sollte man natürlich auch nicht kritisieren dass hier eine solidaritätsbekundung stattfindet zu diesen protesten ne sie ist halt nur auch wieder in der in der eleganz missglückt.
Grammatikalisch fragwürdig aber inhaltlich absolut berechtigt.
Ja also hat er hat halt auch ein schlechtes bild abgegeben aber okay so über diese demonstration berichtete jetzt also dieser youtube-kanal war louis,
daily der von
funk auch unterhalten wird funk ist ja dieser öffentlich-rechtliche zusammenschluss der im youtube formate produziert viele davon denke ich von durchaus nennenswerter
qualität und ehrlich gesagt würde ich sagen ich habe mir ein paar videos angeschaut auch dieses walum scheint mir nicht
nicht von schlechter qualität zu sein allerdings fand sich darin dann folgende stelle die der tim jetzt mal kurz einspielen kann.
Moment was mir ein bisschen zu schnell.
Ich kann ja noch kurz dazu sagen also es wurde nämlich dort eingespielt was ihr gleich hören werdet ein ausschnitt aus logbuch freiheit wiederum
dem youtube format das ich ja hier schon öfter angesprochen habe dass ich zusammen mit lea beckmann,
von der gesellschaft für freiheitsrechte mache in der wir uns ja primär mit freiheitsrechten auseinandersetzen und in der folge um dies jetzt geht das war unsere erste folge da sprechen wir über versammlungsfreiheit,
im look down das ist der ausschnitt den ihr gleich hören werdet aber entscheidend ist hier eher der kontext.
Ja also da werde ich jetzt mal ruckzuck zum mitglied von rebellion der träume und zum veranstalter dieser demonstration die ich übrigens,
nicht besucht habe und pikant ist das ganze deshalb weil
auf also in dem video wird eine facebook-seite gezeigt von rebellion der träumer auf der auch groß steht dass dort ein video läuft was von united stream stammt also steht johanniter stream und alex präsentieren und dass es offenbar
erschienen auf der facebook-seite von rebellion der träume aber da steht auch dran dass es kein inhalt von rebellion der träumer ist steht auch im.
Impressum von logbuch freiheit auf logbuch minus freiheit punkt de das ist eben unter schirmherrschaft der gesellschaft für freiheitsrechte oder zumindest im,
medien rechtlichen verantwortlichkeit der gesellschaft für freiheitsrechte veröffentlicht wird und auch im youtube-video ist steht immer dabei dass das eben leer beckmann linus neumann gesellschaft für freiheitsrechte und ja linus neumann bin einfach ich.
Veröffentlicht wird und ist also ein ein sehr offensichtlicher recherche fehler der folgendermaßen wahrscheinlich zustande gekommen ist also diese logbuch freiheit folgen werden ja über united stream,
veröffentlicht das ist diese ja auch berliner club kulturszene die eben diese,
dj streams macht und auch ein talkformat hat das inzwischen wöchentlich.
Stattfindet und dort werden wird logbuch freiheit auch als bestandteil der sendung immer mit.
Ausgesendet ja also die kriegen die videos von uns und streamen sie dann in ihrem talk so und.
Bei facebook ich kann es jetzt nur.
Also hier redet jetzt der blinde von der farbe bei facebook gibt es offenbar so eine art posting feature ja das also united stream streamt und das erscheint dann.
Als livestream auf fast auf mehreren facebookseiten eine davon ist offenbar die von rebellion der träumer was jetzt offenbar passiert ist ist dass die die redaktion von valulis daily.
Diese facebook-seite angeschaut hat dort den stream gefunden hat dort irgendwie sich angeschaut hat das
und dieses zitat gefunden hat von mir und lea im gespräch jetzt muss ich aber sagen auch am anfang der sendung stellen wir uns ja vor und sagen ich bin linus neumann das ist leer beckmann von der gesellschaft für freiheitsrechte also auch wenn ihr das video geguckt hätten wäre,
da drin klar gewesen dass wir nicht rebellion der träumer sind und ja dann haben sie jetzt halt quasi einfach,
daraus gemacht wir hätten diese veranstaltung veranstaltung da wären ihr vital der rebellion der träume das ist leider oder zum glück wie auch immer unwahr ja das video.
Linus ich glaube dir kein wort ich glaube dir kein wort das du bist auch du steckst auch hinter allem.
Ich stecke hinter allem ja genau jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich folgendes gemacht ich würde dann über twitter von mehreren
logbuch netzpolitik hörern und freunden darüber informiert zu dem zeitpunkt hatte dieses video ungefähr zwanzigtausend views ja dann habe ich eine nachricht geschrieben an.
Die im impressum hinterlegten adressen und habe eine
ein löschen des videos und eine richtig stellung verlangt wie es ja mein recht ist wenn eine falsche tatsachenbehauptungen über mich getätigt wird die noch dazu im rufschädigend ist weil ich meine,
wenn wenn man mir unterstellt ich hätte eine corona party veranstaltet das empfinde ich als meinem ruf nicht zuträglich.
Und jetzt sind's ja jetzt also ich habe dann relativ schnell auch von dem philipp selber eine e-mail bekommen in der du gefragt hat okay was genau stimmt nicht erkläre mal eben wir nehmen das sofort raus und er hat dann.
Relativ zügig diese stelle aus dem video entfernt und in dem in der beschreibung zum video ein eine richtig stellung,
hinzugefügt zwar und zwar noch irgendwie weiß ich nicht innerhalb von sama gefühlt nach stunde oder so ja.
Das ist also denke ich sehr gut und das hätte man bei anderen bei vielen anderen youtubern wahrscheinlich nie erlebt dass so etwas passiert muss ich ganz klar sagen,
allerdings da würde ich schon eine kritik äußern weil zwischen der zeit wo
quasi der empfang meiner beschwerde bestätigt wurde ja über twitter hier hallo habe ich gehört
und dass tatsächlich dieses video dann ersetzt wurde durch ein anderes haben's immerhin noch siebzehntausend leute gesehen
was ich dann also das wäre jetzt quasi der vermeidbare teil gewesen wenn das video offline genommen worden wäre das denke ich wäre.
Wäre eigentlich schon gewesen dass ich mir das gewünscht hätte dass dieses video dann einfach wieder auf privat geschaltet und ersetzt wird.
Seit wann kann man denn bei youtube überhaupt videos ersetzen und die url bleibt selber.
Wenn du ein pro account hast kannst du das machen als ja ja dann kannst du das video quasi nach nachträglich ändern und das ist das geht man provokant ja.
Okay das war mir noch nicht bewusst.
Davon dieser von diesem feature haben die offenbar dann aber da hat er dann offenbar gebrauch gemacht.
Einer der gründe warum ich generell von der nutzung von von youtube abgesehen habe bisher dass man keinerlei möglichkeit hat zu korrigieren.
Ja also also das das geht aber du musst dann eben pro sein ja ich hatte jetzt dann.
Ja also meine ich habe dann dazu geschrieben so ne als als antwort wie gesagt wir hatten da so einen kleinen austausch.
Habe ich gesagt mal philipp vielen dank für die schnelle reaktion ich habe gerade bei youtube reingeschaut das neue video ist schon online freut mich dass wir das so schnell aus der welt schaffen konnten nach bild
trosten und risa habe ich in den letzten tagen viel über medien seniert ich frage mich wie lang oder erfolglos ich wohl bei anderen formaten um eine korrektur hätte bitten müssen vielen dank für schnelligkeit und aufrichtigkeit muss vorher einfach mal sagen weil du gerade sagt dass youtube und so weiter hier also
ein format das ein fehler anerkennt.
Und korrigiert wie gesagt ich hätte mir gewünscht dass das video offline genommen wird andererseits kann ich mir vorstellen dass hier auch eine abwägung stattgefunden hat was nämlich passiert wenn man so ein video was dann einmal durch die ganzen sozialen medien gerollt wurde wenn man das offline nimmt
gibt's ja auch direkt wieder so eine lawine von leuten die sagen das video ist offline und das dann irgendwie was weiß ich reposten und hasse alles nicht gesehen insofern.
Kann man hier auch dafür argumentieren einfach so schnell wie möglich das video zu ändern.
Ja also mein kommentar eben bezug auf youtube war kein inhaltlicher natur sand rein technischer natur ja um das mal gleich nach mal klarzustellen viel klarstellung heute alles muss alles muss klargestellt werden sofort.
Genau aber ich ich denke das passt so ein bisschen zu dem was wieso auch anspricht dass hier hier jemand.
Ansprechbar ist für einen,
für einen fehler ja der fehler passieren es wäre völlig unsinnig als journalistin oder als wissenschaftlerin davon auszugehen dass man nie dass einem nie fehler unterlaufen und das was eben dann,
würde und ehre ausmacht ist der umgang damit und der hat hier eben stattgefunden und zwar nach meinem,
waren nach meiner wahrnehmung ja so schnell wie,
ja im weiter im weitesten sinne möglich und auf korrekte art und weise ja es sind ja auch wie mit fehlern umzugehen ist ist ja auch ne.
Dokumentiert dass er bekannt ist ja nicht so als müsste man nicht wie man mit fehlern umgeht,
im rahmen einer veröffentlichung also hier insgesamt dann war ich doch sehr positiv überrascht auch wenn ich natürlich sagen mich das schon schmerzt wenn da halt ein
acht minuten oder zwölf minuten video oder wie lange das ist,
irgendwie scherze über leute gemacht werden am ende gesagt wird das war ich jetzt.
Naja gut also also ich kann mir das durchaus vorstellen es lässt sich an diese reaktion jetzt auch absehen dass das ihnen das auch schon recht peinlich gewesen sein dürfte und.
Ich weiß ja auch immer wie es mir geht wenn ich irgendwas raushaue ja und ich kriege dann irgendwie kommentar in die sendung mit ja hier aber das.
Falsch so ja also habt ihr ja falsch berichtet habt ihr ja falsch gerechnet meine bar uns jetzt bei logbuch politik,
kommt das natürlich auch vor dass wir mal irgendwas verdrehen so nicht jetzt absichtlich verdrehen sondern dass man einfach was verdreht einfach so im kopf das eine sagen will aber dass das andere rauskommt.
Oder man sich eine quelle vertan hat oder in der zeit also fehler sind normal und auch der fehler ist ja sehr nachvollziehbar ich meine man guckt sich diesen screenshot an und wenn man da halt nicht dieses blaue was war das irgendwie wurde retweetet von.
Sieht dann.
Man sieht sogar in dem screenshot von dem video steht ja sogar united stream und alex tv ja also der offene kanal.
Ja aber es steht halt überall alles mögliche.
Total verstehen ich kann das total verstehen wie es zu so einem fehler kommt und wie gesagt nicht der fehler ist das entscheidende sondern der umgang damit und der ist hier denke ich schon
so wie es hätte sein,
so so wie es hätte sein sollen und vor allem in einer geschwindigkeit die mit der ich jetzt nicht gerechnet habe ich habe da im prinzip eigentlich gesessen habe gedacht boah der zähler von diesem video schießt in die höhe also tausend views im
takt weniger minuten kommen dazu und ich konnte mir quasi anschauen wie.
Richter ein reputationen lasse so runterzählen sehen so.
Na ja das war's dann mit der karriere.
Corona party veranstaltet.
Also gibt ein bienchen für die reaktion alles gut genutzt hat dich wieder lieb wir haben schlechtere beispiele.
Nicht wieder ich kannte den vorher nicht muss ich aufzugeben aber offenbar ne aber viele viele.
Ich schon aber ja.
Viele leute die auch irgendwie netzpolitik hören haben eben auch so ja geschrieben so krass das hätte ich nicht gedacht dass,
dass da so etwas passiert dass es eigentlich eine qualitativ hochwertige sendung und so die wenigen anderen videos die ich mir dann da noch so beispielhaft angeschaut habe machen auch den eindruck.
Gucken wir mal wie viele kommentare noch kommen mit ja hier linus und so weiter du machst auch selber corona party habe ich schon ein bisschen im internet gesehen muss wahr sein.
Ich mache korinna partys im internet,
kommen wir zu einem anderen beispiel wo jemand ich auch in der zeit seit der letzten sendung.
Ich denke ebenfalls
also noch viel noch viel offenkundig nachweisbar falsche und auch ja wie ich empfinde ehrverletzender äußerungen tätigt und zwar ist das der allseits bekannte und beliebte.
Jan fleischhauer also fleischhauer ist ein ja wie soll man das sagen also ein kolumnist.
Rechts außeren rande dessen was gesellschaftlich akzeptabel ist
also sehr genau an diesem rand und hat sehr viele jahre
beim spiegel gearbeitet und vor einigen jahren ist er dann zum fokus gewechselt ich denke eine publikation die ihm eine sehr viel bessere heimat bietet was jetzt die gesamte hinsichtlich der journalistischen qualität und politischen ausrichtung.
Für die formulierung das jetzt von mir ein bienchen.
Ist doch wahr.
Ja ja es ist alles super.
Entwickelte.
Das verdrehen von fakten könne leben gefährden sagte justizministerin der war gefährder ist aber nicht der corona demonstrant der sich vor dem viren chip fürchtet es ist der netz aktivist der die tracing app,
überwachungs- instrument denunziert,
also das man merkt auch hier so ne diese denunzieren das sind ja auch so ein wort das liest da gerne bei donald von so das liste bei fleischhauer und ansonsten kenne ich das eigentlich nur aus,
ja schriften und reden die ein paar jahrzehnte alt sind.
Ja gefährlicher als attila hildmann der irgendwie mit der waffe in der hand in staatsoper stürzen möchte.
Ja also und dann habe ich verlinkt ist da ein ein artikel von ihm oder eine kolumne von ihm.
Die ich jetzt mal als fleischhauer aus verdrehten fakten bezeichnen möchte und zwar schreibt er da über ja letztendlich hat hat einen artikel in der zeit gelesen dass muss,
hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht dass er sowas tut und hat den halt zum anlass genommen über die deutsche corona app zu sanieren,
und ich habe mir jetzt tatsächlich mal die mühe gemacht diese ganze reihe aus verdrehten fakten die ihr dort,
darstellt mal aufzubröseln ich habe übrigens auch das möchte ich vielleicht zu transparenz noch sagen auf diesen tweet geantwortet und habe ihm gesagt wenn ich ihnen ein also weil er ja also durch dieses diese artikel er redet immer von verdrehten fakten
benennt zwar keine aber unterstellt welche habe ich ihn gesagt wenn wir doch hier von verdrehten fakten reden wie wäre das denn wenn ich ihnen jetzt ein oder mehrere verdrehte fakten.
Nachweise und zwar belegt nachweise veröffentlichen sie dann eine richtig stellung.
Das ist eine ganz normale würde man jetzt den journalisten von einem journalisten die einzige antwort die darauf.
Angemessen ist es einfach ein selbstverständlich hatte aber ignoriert also zeigt auch hat auch in der vergangenheit selten interesse gezeigt seine behauptungen und falsch behauptungen zu korrigieren.
Also darauf hat er nicht reagiert okay,
ich zitiere er schreibt also über die deutsche corona app.
Wo schreibt er das.
Im fokus und er hat also leitet ein über und zwar handling der pandemien in südkorea.
Und sagt dann aber in deutschland ne wird ja nicht mit harter hand regierte so ungefähr es quasi der tonus auf jeden fall schreibt der bundesgesundheitsminister persönlich hat sich hinter die sache geklemmt im mai,
sollte es auch bei uns losgehen aber dann traten die netzaktivisten vom chaos computer club auf die bühne und sagten dass der datenschutz nicht gewährleistet sei falsch.
Erstens,
ich habe schon im märz das dezentrale modell beschrieben und unterstützt gibt's meinen blogpost der relativ häufig zitiert und verlinkt wurde und es gibt da auch seitdem mehrere logbuch folgen zu aber insbesondere die zur
corona tracing das bin ja jetzt nur ich der netzaktivisten der cfc selber hat schon im april.
Die prüfsteine veröffentlicht auch die haben wir hier diskutiert übrigens kleine anmerkung die prüfsteine wurden inzwischen in dem dokumentations- von,
der corona warn-app gewürdigt indem nämlich die quasi ein dokument veröffentlicht haben indem sie,
quasi ihre compliance mit den prüfstein.
Erklären ja sozusagen folgende schutzmaßnahmen haben wir um diesen prüfstein zu erfüllen ja was also bedeutet eine sehr konstruktiv angenommen hier und,
eben auch belegt dass wir mit diesem prüfstein ein einfluss haben auf die ausrichtung und entwicklung der corona app die kommen wird.
Die technischen prüfsteine muss man dazu sagen.
Die technischen prüfsteine genau,
wir haben auch gesellschaftliche aber genau es gibt die technische drittens der cfc hat im mai nichts zum datenschutz gesagt ist nämlich eine juristische frage wir sprechen immer nur über technik wir sind ja keine juristen.
Und was wir gefordert haben ist von der bundesregierung dass von ihr
präferierte konzept für eine tracing app gegen die korona pandemien aufzugeben verfolgt sie dieses konzept weiter kann kein vertrauen bei den nutzern aufkommen und ein scheitern wäre unausweichlich ja also wir haben nicht
gesagt
wir haben nicht gesagt diese corona müsste aufgehört werden oder sonst was dann wir haben gesagt das konzept muss ein dezentrales sein,
so fleischhauer schreibt weiter seitdem ist die szene heillos zerstritten.
Die beteiligten it-experten verbrachten mehr zeit damit sich gegenseitig mit vorwurf vorwürfen zu überziehen als mit dem code falsch.
Falsch eins einfach nur falsch denn fakt ist der streit innerhalb von peppi lag nicht am c,
der veröffentlichung im mai unseres offenen briefes sondern an der schlechten kommunikation der projektverantwortlichen also innerhalb von peppi gab es einen streit und diesen streit habe ich ja sogar hier auch kritisiert und hab gesagt es nicht in ordnung,
ihr seid jetzt konstruktiv zusammenarbeiten und euch nicht in der öffentlichkeit zanken und das lag eben an der schlechten projektförderung von,
per pdf dass das so eskaliert ist und nicht an uns zweitens dieser veröffentlichung im mai also der offene brief des c und mehrere anderer organisationen an die bundesregierung.
War quasi markierte das ende des streits der streit hat quasi vorher stattgefunden.
Ein tag nach unserem öffentlichen nach unserem offenen brief ist die bundesregierung ja umgeschwenkt auf das dezentrale konzept das heißt dieser gesamte streit ging unserer unserem offenen brief voran.
Nicht wurde nicht dadurch ausgelöst drittens,
genau also nachdem wir diesen brief veröffentlicht haben wurde dieser streit beendet und zwar durch bundeskanzleramt,
höchstpersönlich ne helge braun hat dann bekannt gegeben wir verfolgen jetzt den dezentralen ansatz.
Weiterhin macht der fleischhauer hier eine wie ich denke nicht entschuldbar auslassung denn entscheidend für das umschwenken der bundesregierung auf ein dezentralen ansatz.
Ist und bleibt die entscheidung von apple und google die diese am gründonnerstag bekannt gegeben haben nämlich dass sie nur ein dezentrales modell unterstützen werden.
Ja das heißt
ich denke es ist ja sehr schön ich freue mich ja ich habe mich auch schon gefreut als jasper von alten bock rum und dafür gescholten hat dass nur eine dezentrale app möglich ist entscheidend ist aber es geht eben nur eine dezentrale app und diesen teil lässt er vollständig aus ja apple google technische frank
überhaupt spielen gar keine rolle zweitens auch die von ihm gepriesen koreanische app kann nicht funktioniert haben weil es zu diesem zeitpunkt.
Kein framework gab und keine möglichkeit auf iphones eine corona app.
Umzusetzen dabei gleichzeitig noch angemerkt das gilt übrigens auch für die gestern oder wann veröffentlichte französische app überhaupt können solche corona apps nur funktionieren seitdem.
Apple und google dieses framework freigeschaltet haben und der letzten woche hatten wir ja bereits erwähnt dass inzwischen,
die schweiz eine darauf basieren der app veröffentlicht hat und sicherlich weißt du ob es noch andere länder.
Also veröffentlicht sind die apps bisher in italien und in lettland und in der schweiz gibt's eine bittere phase und,
wahrscheinlich auch bald veröffentlicht sein und deutschland sind wir ja mitte juni dabei also es gibt jetzt quasi zwei die tatsächlich schon im app store sind lettland italien
und ich rechne mit schweiz österreich deutschland demnächst also das wird wahrscheinlich sogar mehr oder weniger zeitgleich stattfinden könnte ich mir gut vorstellen.
So weiter schreibt fleischhauer vielleicht kommt die apps jetzt im juni vielleicht auch erst im herbst oder pünktlich mit dem impfstoff falsch in den an dem tag.
An dem fleischhauer diese kolumne veröffentlicht hat hat sap,
den code der app auf github veröffentlicht schon davor hatten sie wir hatten das hier auch erwähnt.
Den backend veröffentlicht die veröffentlichung der app ist in wenigen tagen anberaumt ja man spricht hier irgendwie so von einem bereich im,
sag mal nächste spätestens übernächste woche ja also.
Richtung der bundesregierung hört man sowas wie kalenderwoche fünfundzwanzig und das bedeutet natürlich dass die app davor schon fertig sein muss also falsch.
Und.
Es wird hier wieder der eindruck erweckt eine die eine zentrale app hätte funktional sein können und das ist nachweisbar einfach nicht der fall und diese von ihm immer wieder wiederholte falsche voraussetzungen,
die grundlage für die gesamte argumentation die er da aufbaut hätte die bundesregierung diese entscheidung nicht getroffen stünden wir heute immer noch da mit einer zentralen app die auf iphones nicht unterstützt wird.
Und die hätten wir in diesem jahr auch nicht mehr bekommen aus ganz klar sagen die zentrale app ist und bleibt eine sackgasse,
und das lässt er vollkommen außen vor er schreibt dann weiter
wie der koreaner sagt eine freiheit muss im kampf gegen die pandemien dran glauben die koreaner haben sich entschieden auf etwas privatsphäre zu verzichten um sich im gegenzug ihre bewegungsfreiheit zu bewahren wir opfern lieber die freiheit uns zu bewegen damit unsere daten in sicherheit sind
so das ist falsch denn.
Die bewegungsfreiheit wird nicht geopfert stattdessen gibt's gerade weiträumige lockerungen und zwar schon seit wochen in deutschland ja also bewegungsfreiheit wird gerade ausgebaut mit oder ohne korona app und das wiederholt hier wieder eine,
offenkundige und belegte falsch darstellung dass die corona app in irgendeiner form voraussetzung für bewegungsfreiheit sei ja wir haben bewegungsfreiheit längst wieder.
Und zwar mit oder ohne app.
Hatten sie auch nie so richtig nie so richtig verloren also zumindest nicht in dem maße wie es in anderen ländern der fall ist aber jetzt ist es halt auch überhaupt nicht mehr der fall.
Richtig ja das ist das ist denke ich auch noch ein wichtiger punkt es gab nämlich gar keine
also es gab einschränkungen der bewegungsfreiheit es gab aber kein lok down wir in anderen ländern stattgefunden hat und zweitens und das ist hier wieder ein erneut es gibt überhaupt gar kein gegensatz.
Und keine abwägung zwischen privatsphäre und bewegungsfreiheit denn.
Genau dafür gibt es ja diese dezentrale lösung also privatsphäre braucht nicht geopfert zu werden.
Und das für diese app und deswegen wird sie auch nicht geopfert.
Also das gegensatzpaar was er da aufmacht ist.
Nicht in der realität vorhanden eine contact dressing app funktioniert kann privatsphäre basierend funktionieren und das tut sie auch und es ist quasi ein widerspruch den es nicht gibt.
Weiter schreibt er der merkt man auch auf welchem niveau der mann schreibt das ergibt wenn man darüber nachdenkt dafür hat er nachgedacht ne auch sinn doppelpunkt der computer-nerd bleibt ohnehin am liebsten zuhause.
Auch das ist falsch unzulässige verallgemeinerung ich bin sehr gerne nicht zuhause.
Ja bist du denn überhaupt einen computer nerds.
Ja genau dann da mich wahrscheinlich kein computer nerds und ne das ist ja eine eine gezielte hauptwirkung einer vollständigen bevölkerungsgruppe und das ist natürlich etwas was,
jetzt bei beim fokus auch keine seltenheit ist insofern wie gesagt kann man das nur mal hier als stilmittel durchaus in frage stellen.
Ja vor allem hätte er mal nachfragen können bei den ganzen familie dieser computer-nerds wo wollen sie nämlich eilig in die wohl alle immer nach leipzig auf dem kongress und nicht zuhause rumsitzen.
Ja genau.
So sieht's nämlich aus.
Also ist wirklich so dann schreibt ihr als nächstes normalerweise muss uns die welt sich des hacker nicht weiter bekümmert wenn sich der chaos computer club vor dem merkel totalitarismus fürchtet sei es drum falsch.
Erstens der chaos computer club fürchtet sich nicht vor allem merkel totalitarismus das ist eine.
Paar was man eher in anderen veröffentlichungen liest für die übrigens jan fleischhauer schreibt da komme ich später noch mal zu zweitens der chaos computer club hat auch noch nie vor einem
mehr merkel totalitarismus gesprochen ist das erste mal dass ich dieses wort überhaupt ausspreche wie man an meinen schwierigkeiten diesen satz zu sagen merkt.
Und ja dieser begriff entstammt eher den rechtsextremen kreisen in den herr fleischhauer ja auch nachweislich,
verkehrt wie gesagt dazu komme ich später er schreibt weiter.
Wenn die netzgemeinde allerdings das wichtigste instrument zu fall bringt dass wir zur bekämpfung des virus bräuchten wird es heikel.
Falsch erstens wir haben überhaupt nichts zu fall gebracht sondern konstruktiv an der debatte mitgewirkt ja,
der die app wird laut telekom und sap in wenigen tagen veröffentlicht und sap hat sich wie vom c empfohlen nach dem prüfstein des c beurteilt und das ergebnis veröffentlicht ja wir haben überhaupt nichts zu fall gebracht sondern wir haben hier etwas
außerdem kann man natürlich noch sagen es gibt arge zweifel.
Von sämtlichen experten dass die app das wichtigste,
instrument zur bekämpfung des virus sei ich denke und das habe ich ja auch immer vertreten dass eine atemschutzmaske sicherlich um einiges wichtiger ist.
Das also sagen wir mal so kommt immer drauf an was man hier als das eigentliche instrument ansieht
contact tracing ja das stimmt contracting ist wahrscheinlich das wichtigste instrument nur diese app ist nicht das contact tracing sie ist ein.
Ein tool von dem man hofft dass es das contact dressing verbessern und beschleunigen kann nichts nicht mehr nicht weniger.
Richtig jetzt schreibt er weiter das ist der satz den auch getwittert hat das leugnen und verdrehen von fakten
und können in der pandemien leben gefährden hat bundesjustizministerin christine lambrecht mit blick auf die corona demos gesagt vielleicht könnt ihr die ministerin auch einmal ein wort an die netzgemeinde richten damit legt er im prinzip nahe
wir würden fakten leugnen oder verdrehen gibt es zwei interessante punkte erstens,
hat der c im gegensatz zu jan fleischhauer keine fakten verdreht geleugnet oder ausgelassen.
Und zweitens ist es hier ein sehr interessantes rhetorische weil er keine fakten benennt.
Der c oder die netzgemeinde verdreht oder geleugnet hätte er so.
Tätig diese unterstellung diese falsche unterstellung einfach ohne ein beispiel ja den ganzen artikel steht nicht folgenden fakt,
hat der c geäußert dieser fakt ist falsch nein das einzige was er im c überhaupt unterstellt ist er fürchtete sich vor dem merkel totalitarismus das ist,
nicht korrekt und wir hätten uns über über um den datenschutz geschert was ebenfalls nicht,
eine nicht haltbare aussage ist natürlich spielt spielen datenschutz konsequenzen eine rolle aber die einlassung des c.
Sind immer technischer und weniger juristischer natur insbesondere wenn es hier um diese corona app geht.
Im technischen teil so dann macht er weiter mit,
der corona demonstrant der sich vor dem viren chip fürchtet ist nur ein trottel der netzaktivisten der die tracing app als überwachungs- instrument denunziert ist ein gefährder.
Falsch wir haben die tracing app nicht als überwachungs- instrumenten und ziert sondern dazu beigetragen dass sie zielgerichtet funktioniert und kein überwachungs- instrument,
ist oder wird wir haben das ja schon eingangs gesagt ne zentral hat das potenzial zum überwachungs- instrument dezentralen nicht dezentral hat sich durchgesetzt weltweit und das nicht,
unbedingt nur wegen uns auch wenn ich mich natürlich freue wenn dem c hier ein teil der lorbeeren auch zugestanden wird.
Zweitens ist es natürlich eine herabwürdigenden und haltlosen beleidigung menschen als
oder aktivisten als gefährder zu bezeugen
zu bezeichnen abschließend möchte nochmal sagen betont mehrmals der cfc oder netzaktivisten hätten fakten verdreht benennt aber keine fakten die wir vertreten hätten und das ist sicherlich
kein zufall man könnte jetzt das ganze mit emotionalität entschuldigen wenn der mann nicht seit über dreißig jahren als journalist tätig wäre was er da macht.
Ist kalkül also entweder hat er mit kalkül sich in eine debatte eingebracht die er in keiner form überhaupt nicht im entferntesten verfolgt hat.
Oder das denke ich ist hier doch eher zu vermuten er hat gezielt fakten ausgelassen um.
Einfach auf ein lieblingsfilm einzuschlagen denn.
Jan fleischhauer hat ich glaube zweitausendneun ein buch darüber geschrieben wie er in einem ja linken links bürgerlichen haushalt
aufgewachsen ist und da offenbar mit einigen verhaltensweisen seines umfeldes und seiner erziehungsberechtigten nicht einverstanden war was ihn dann eben dazu gebracht hat ein sich politisch dann rechts außen zu beheimaten.
Und er ist quasi dafür bekannt einfach ähnlich wie jasper von alten bochum regelmäßig bürgerrechtsbewegung und sonstige ja anzugreifen und mit.
Selten fundierten vorwürfen zu überhäufen also auch sonstige beiträge von jan fleischhauer haben regelmäßig ähnliche oder schwerere handwerkliche mängel er zeigt kein interesse an einer korrektur.
Und ich denke es ist unverantwortlich derartige unwahrheiten und verdrehungen im rahmen eines magazins zu veröffentlichen das
sich als journalistisches erzeugnis verkauft ja insbesondere ich erinnere daran der fokus jahrelang geworben sein damaliger gründer helmut markwort hieß der glaube ich fakten fakten fakt.
Das ist hier einfach mal nicht der fall,
denke das ist ein offenbarungseid für fokus und dass diese art von berichterstattung mit so vielen auslassung mit so vielen verdrehungen und falschen unterstellungen ist eben auf einer ebene mit zum attila hildmann mit,
kein jason und mit dem kopf verlag ja da erwartet man ähnliche haltloses vorwürfe und ignoranz gegenüber einfach tatsachen.
Spannend ist wie gesagt er macht keinerlei anstalten solche unwahren behauptungen zu korrigieren ich habe ihn angeschrieben ja und genau das ist es nämlich wovor wieso warnt ja also beispiel eins hier war lollis.
Youtuber macht eine falsche klingt ein hinweis von mir setz dich noch nachts um elf dran schneidet ein neues video veröffentlicht das.
Hat halt einen begriff von journalistischer ehre und fleischhauer ist einfach nur daran interessiert andere zu ja beschimpfen und das eben unter.
Vorspiegelung falscher tatsachen das sind genau die schwarzen schafe,
von denen sich die seriöse presse distanzieren und abheben soll statt solchen desinformationskampagnen ein podium zu geben und das ist spezifisch das was risa eben am ende seines videos auch sagt so wenn ihr euch von wenn ihr,
theoretiker kritisieren wollt dann müsst ihr anders arbeiten so ich habe jetzt gesagt dass der fleischhauer.
Am rechts außeren rand von geschmack und anstand ist und dem was politisch in deutschland noch tolerable ist das muss ich natürlich noch belegen.
Er war autor des webbox die achse des guten ja das ja primär durch ja eine sehr anti-amerikanismus haltung aber auch.
Oder nein eine sehr proaktiv haltung.
Eine sehr ja sagen wir mal kapitalismus konforme haltung und vor allem eine klimakrise kritische haltung.
Bekannt ist insbesondere aber durch seine anti-islamischen beiträge bekannt wurde
also ein ein ein medium das anti-islam ist klimaleugner und pro am tisch und pro kapitalistisch ist das ist so der
das ist eine der heimaten die er hatte.
Und eben klimawandel skeptische beiträge finden wir auf der achse des guten weiterhin ist er laut wikipedia autor auf freie welt punkt net,
oder gewesen ja also er hat,
beiträge auf freie welt punkt net veröffentlicht die seite kannte ich gar nicht habe ich mal besucht beispiel titel der webseite freie welt einfach nur heute als ich drauf geschaut habe.
Grüne korona verschwörung und biologische realitäten.
Linksextreme gewalt in den usa präsident sieht in der antifa eine terrorgruppe naturschutz gelaber vom umweltminister.
Orban und bolsonaro als sündenböcke wer daran interesse hat und dann einen artikel unter dem titel,
am antisemitismus sind größtenteils die juden schuld und dann noch eine umfrage.
Unter der fragestellung linksextreme gewalt us präsident donald trump will antifa als terrororganisation einstufen soll man das auch in deutschland tun als ich mir das angeschaut habe gab es zu dieser aussage neun achtundneunzig prozent zustimmung unter den lesen wo bin ich
hier gelandet ja erstmal browser history gelöscht damit falls ihr mal irgendwie jemand guckt und denkt ich lese ja irgendwie solche rechtsextremen publikationen.
Nicht ein bisschen dazu informiert das medium teil das medium freie welt punkt net,
teil des vereins netzwerks zivile koalition der afd-politiker beatrix und sven von storch ja also in afd publikation für die er da,
geschrieben hat.
Er pflegt außerdem freundschaften zu bekannten rex rechtsextrem nicht kontakte sondern nach seiner aussage spezifisch spezifisch freundschaften und ist auch nicht das erste mal dass er sich rassismus
vorwürfen aussetzen muss und schließlich möchte ich nochmal sagen jan fleischhauer verletzt regelmäßig journalistische standards stellt fakten verdreht und unvollständig da,
und zeigt kein interesse falsch darstellungen zu korrigieren ich werde ihm auch diesen ausschnitt der sendung natürlich
zusenden um ihn da mal mit seinen falsch darstellungen zu konfrontieren und ich bin dann sehr gespannt ob ein solcher,
mensch die größe hat ja seine unwahrheiten dann zu richtig richtig zu stellen und zu korrigieren.
Oder ob ich mich auf keine reaktion keine direkte reaktion und im zweifelsfall nur einen neuen angriff durch diesen,
rechts außen.
Verklärt dieser welt vorbereiten muss da bin ich sehr gespannt ich schätze dass er weiterhin keine reaktion zeigen wird und seine,
verunglimpfende falschen tatsachenbehauptungen unkorrigiert dort stehen lassen wird und das ist das.
Da gehe ich fest von aus das sage ich jetzt hier auch deshalb um ihn dazu zu treten das vielleicht doch zu machen.
Aber ich glaube nicht dass das dieser mann also er hat auch in vergangenheit selten irgendwie einsicht oder größe gezeigt das ist jemand den hellste dir als redaktion.
Damit du irgendwo so den den rechten rand markieren kannst damit er als als,
als kleines gewürz in deiner publikation ist der hat ja im spiegel auch wirklich keine politische heimat ne er war da sie kolumne heißt ja der schwarze kanal was übrigens ein lassen wir das ja also.
Ostbürger erinnern sich vielleicht noch.
Ja also ein ein der der ist da um zu polarisieren um genau das zu tun was er macht aber er entfernt sich da eben von den,
fakten und verletzt journalistische standards und das ist nicht akzeptabel wenn er sagt er möchte gerne in
deutschland eine zentrale korona mit zentraler überwachung und was weiß ich fußfessel funktionalität und so das kann er gerne vertreten aber.
Dann muss er das eben vor der faktenlage tun und nicht unter.
Weitestgehende auslassung der kompletten gesellschaftlichen diskussion und falsch darstellung der tatsache das geht eben nicht also auch für.
Rechtsaußen journalisten und kolumnistin gilt eben der anspruch des journalistischen standards und den verletzt er hier und zwar absichtlich.
Viel feind viel er ja also so wie er auf dem c rumhackt habe ich zu den eindruck der club mal wieder eine ganze menge richtig gemacht.
Ja das ist natürlich das ist das andere es ist natürlich eine besondere adelung ja wenn man solche.
Ja also es ist es zeigt sich ja auch eine gewisse hilflosigkeit ja in diesem vorwürfen in diesem beschimpfungen in diesem.
Ja verdrehungen und so ja das das zeigt sich natürlich eine hilflosigkeit dass hier eben dieser rechtsaußen aussieht dass ja deutungshoheit verloren geht ja und der die.
Ja die die grund- und freiheitsrechte und die aufgeklärte gesellschaft eben weiterhin im weg stehen.
Das ist natürlich eine eine gewisse würdigung die man erfährt wenn man sich solche ja,
schriften eintritt aber ändert nichts daran dass das eben leider für den stand der
journalistinnen und journalisten eine ja ein ein ein schandfleck ist ja von dem ich denke sie müssten sich durchaus distanzieren.
Freie welt junge freiheit freiheit aber also wenn es euch immer irgendwas nicht geht dann darum das ist wirklich das absurdeste da dran an dem ist auch die app scheißegal und es geht ja einfach nur darum ein aufhänger zu haben,
ordentlich wieder auf die linken zu boxen weil es so.
Ich habe noch den wikipedia artikel von zu jan fleischhauer.
In die shownotes gemacht da finden sich die belege zu sein dass er eben rechtsextreme als seine freunde bezeichnet während,
die das wiederum nicht tun also ja ganz unangenehmer ganz unangenehmer publikation,
und leider auch dass man noch zu sagen ist das das hat mich auch dann doch gewundert in dem video benennt den fokus als ein positiv beispiel und da muss ich wirklich sagen.
Dem kann ich mich auch nur schwer anschließen weil der fokus ist wirklich ich sag mal die so eine wochenbilanz ne also das ist schon
sehr politisch gefärbt regelmäßig stark ausländerfeindlich in meiner wahrnehmung und,
das ist wirklich keine publikation die man bei der man sich dauerhaft aussetzen kann ohne irgendwie auch irgendwann mal zwischendurch fieber zu messen.
Eine publikation der man sich auch schlecht aussetzen kann ohne regelmäßig fieber zu setzen ist der twitter feed von donald trump.
Ich habe den typen ja geblockt ich weiß ja nicht wie du es so hältst aber ich,
ich bin generell auch auf twitter sehr auf meine eigene mental hygiene bedacht und blog einfach alles weg was mir.
Zu doof ist ja ich weiß blase und so weiter aber der befinde ich mich ohnehin und ich will halt da für mich irgendwie noch ein diskussionsforum freihalten mit dem ich auch,
klar kommen kann ich habe da genug widerspruch und genug kritik die ich wahrnehmen kann die ich mich wirklich kümmern muss aber da gehört jetzt unbedingt jetzt donald trump und seine bigotte vollidioten die im folgen
nicht dazu.
Also ich meine bloggen mach meine primär wenn man möchte dass jemand anderes einen nicht sieht und ich weiß jetzt nicht ob donald trump die sonst gefolgt wäre.
Ja ich will das halt auch gar nicht in meine timeline reingespürt bekommen ich will will will will mich der nicht diesen permanenten ich weiß schon was ich davon halte und
braucht er jetzt keines besseren belehrt zu werden,
ding ist für mich durch und genauso wenn halt irgendwelche anderen schreien meine timeline reinspringen und auf irgendwas replay rein und irgendwie ja merkel terror und bla,
das sind leute mit denen muss man nicht diskutieren dass da übrigt sich die diskussion ich brauche nicht auf einen tweet von
donald trump replay mit haben sie mal das erwogen ob sie nicht vielleicht hier vielleicht unter umständen eine andere meinung bekommen könnten wenn sie dieses von mir da gereichten argument mal abwägen würden.
Brauche ich nicht zu machen,
so und bei allen leuten bei denen es ähnlich ist bräuchte es halt auch nicht zu machen ich habe auf twitter ehrlich gesagt ganz gute erfahrungen mit offenen diskussion.
Wenn man leuten einfach
sagst du ist nicht so weil oder wenn die mir sagen ist nicht so weil dann gebe ich halt auch zu okay okay ja ich mich wahrscheinlich geirrt,
gibt dann immer wieder ein paar leute die dann ganz entsetzt denn so jemand hat auf twitter seine meinung geändert das streiche ich mir mal rot im kalender an so,
weiß nicht für mich sollte das ich versuche mir das da eine gewisse normalität auch zu erhalten naja.
Also ich ich vermeide ja diskussionen.
Über twitter wenn es geht ja also jetzt wenn man jetzt wirklich etwas diskutieren möchte dass aber natürlich freue ich mich über hinweise und
habe auch insgesamt dann doch muss ich sagen relativ gute erfahrungen mit twitter immer mal wieder tritt man sich da verschiedene spinner ein
den muss man dann manchmal helfen dass sie sich was anderes suchen.
Da hilft dann auch manchmal so ein blog insgesamt gehe ich dabei aber eigentlich spärlich um nur mach das nur dann wenn ich denke es okay ich möchte nicht weiter dass diese person meine inhalte,
wahrnimmt und sich daran abarbeitet oder sich auch in den in den antworten dann ja zum brot macht ne da muss ja dann dann hast du irgendwie einen schönen tweet und dann hast du da drunter.
Es ist auch,
ja ja man ist es auch ein gewisser hinsicht ein selbstschutz gar nicht mal so sehr jetzt wegen dieses ich will das nicht lesen oder so sein mir ist es auch jetzt schon so ein zwei drei mal passiert dass ich durch eine unachtsamkeit.
War jetzt auch wieder so ein bisschen im im thema dieser sendung mir so ein bisschen was hab unterjubeln lassen.
So eine quelle ja und dann.
Nochmal nachgeschaut und dann weißt du dann weiß ich auf leute hin so hier du hast hier grade irgendwie so nazi war das jetzt ernst gemeint nicht so war die,
lösche ich dann natürlich auch sofort und habe mir dann erstmal wieder von kopf alter jetzt erzählst du,
ein die ganze zeit ja und sei vorsichtig und was nicht alles und jetzt bist du selber mal wieder in so einen scheißhaufen getreten.
Einfach weil er irgendwas was ich irgendwas nicht überprüft hast nicht nicht richtig interpretiert hast in dem moment und man man geht halt so einen link dann auch irgendwie schnell mal auf den leim.
Das sind dann natürlich auch alles leute die dann eben auch einfach weggeblockt werden damit sie gar nicht erst in meiner timeline auftauchen um mir irgendwie so eine sprengfalle in den weg zu legen.
Es gibt ein schönes beispiel dafür gerade auf twitter macht die runde in den usa würde kontext
tracing
zur überwachung von demonstrierenden eingesetzt und alle denken natürlich sofort an die contact tracing apps die es nach meiner kenntnis in den usa ebenso wenig bisher gibt wie in deutschland.
Und im artikel zeigt sich dann es geht um was ganz anderes ne ganz andere maßnahmen und technologien die da eben zur demonstrationszug folg eingesetzt werden aber
auch daran merkst du wie viele das requisiten und also hier die corona maßnahmen zur überwachung genutzt und.
Halt nicht den artikel gelesen haben dass das ist sehr weit verbreitetes phänomen auftritt.
In dem artikel ist von tools die rede ja nicht von apps und es wird aber nicht gesagt was für tools das sind es kann natürlich jetzt auch einfach normale werke
zeuge des normalen contact racing selber der artikels an der stelle auch sehr unspezifisch und von daher kann man sich da auch nicht groß zu äußern was damit jetzt eigentlich wirklich gemeint ist.
Naja.
Nichtsdestotrotz stimmt es natürlich dass bei denen staaten und usa ist ja auch so dass die bundesstaaten einzelne apps rausgeben teilweise eben zentrale methoden gibt wo dann eben
der übliche datensammeln wahnsinn dann auch sofort anfängt und
klar könnte so etwas auch dafür verwendet werden wenn jetzt alle mit dieser app rumlaufen und du hast halt ein zentrales modell wo die daten zusammenlaufen ja dann.
Kann eben genau das eben passieren dann kann genauso in missbrauch für solchen demonstrationen stattfinden dass du eben dieses wer mit wem,
da versucht herauszulesen und genau deswegen wollten wir das ja auch nicht aber bleiben wir bei trump denn.
Trump hat ja mal haut ja einfach wahrscheinlich also täglich im minutentakt schwachsinn raus und das verfolgt halt meistens auch irgendeine agenda.
Eine dieser agenda settings ist dass er jetzt verhindern möchte dass ich briefwahl mehr durchsetzen ist ja das problem wir haben
usa vielmehr haben wahlen in november.
Präsidentschaftswahlen wo dann hoffentlich dieser trump dann auch endlich mal entsorgt wird und
generell kann man davon ausgehen dass es schon einen mehrheitlichen widerstand gegen seine politik
gibt ob die sich dann aber eben auch in einer wahl niederschlägt ist ja eine ganz andere sache erstmal hast du diese hürde
der letzte mal hillary clinton schon nicht nehmen konnte dass selbst wenn du mehr stimmen bekommst nicht automatisch präsident wirst sondern es geht dann eben nach diesem wahlmänner stimmen wie das so schön heißt also sprich du musst halt deine
pressing star gewinnen und damit eben die staaten um dann eben alle stimmen eines staates hinter dir versammeln zu können und so kann man eben auch mit weniger stimmen gewinnen.
Verhinderung von.
Der möglichkeit zu wählen bei bestimmten gruppen die einem vielleicht nicht so freundlich gesinnt sind das ist das programm der republikaner schon seit langer langer zeit da gibt es alle möglichen
sachen von leute die knast in dürfen nicht wählen
bis hin zu man muss jetzt irgendeine zeigen die vielleicht viele leute nicht haben oder nicht zeigen wollen bei der wahl all das und natürlich auch dieses gary mentoring wie das so schön heißt also das aufteilen der wahlkreise
aufgrund neuer.
Erkenntnisse darüber werden wo für was wählt sodass man eben sicherstellen kann dass man eine mehrheit in einem wahlkreis noch behält indem man ihn einfach den wahlkreis anders zuschneiden das sind so sachen die einfach seit jahrzehnten,
usus sind und wenn man jetzt aber auch noch sagen würde okay wir verstärken aber jetzt mal die briefwahl weil es ja pandemien würde das wiederum die chancen von vielen leuten wählen zu können erhöhen und deswegen ist der trump halt auch dagegen also
brettert er dann mal raus dass
briefwahl wäre ja sozusagen schon intrinsisch wahlbetrug und die ganzen,
briefwahl boxen würden ja geklaut werden und gefälscht werden und überhaupt und das kann ja wohl nicht sein und fängt an anderen zu feuern,
twittert das irgendwie raus haut es auch auf facebook auf facebook steht das dann halt auch ein möglichen kanäle geteilt auf twitter blendet dann.
Twitter selbst auf einmal ein hinweis ein.
Ich weiß gar nicht seit wann ist diese hinweise gibt dass es ein relativ neues werkzeug dass man jetzt sozusagen die inhalte eines tweets
kommentiert systemseitig also es gibt also irgendein team bei twitter die dann so ein tweet sehen bewerten.
Und dann eben so ein hinweis geben man sieht das ja auch bei youtube überall wenn man jetzt irgendwas über corona virus neunzehn macht gibt's dann immer gleich diesen link hier informationen von der bundeszentrale für gesundheit etcetera.
Um einfach zu verhindern dass ich jetzt hier zu viel fehlinformationen breit macht und sowas ähnliches hat twitter da jetzt eben,
auch rausgehauen fand trump natürlich nicht so geil ist gleich durch die decke gegangen.
Hat irgendwie nicht lange gedauert und der hat irgendwie eine excecutive order unterschrieben das ist ja sozusagen.
Da er hat nicht mal so ohne weiteres in die legislative gehen kann und neue gesetze beschließen kann weil da müsste ja der kongress zustimmen und der ist demokratisch dominiert mittlerweile
gibt es halt immer noch so diese möglichkeit einer executive order das ist so der präsident beschließt jetzt hier einfach mal irgendwas bestimmten rahmen kann,
können bestimmte dinge eben durchgesetzt werden und die ich jetzt nicht näher kommentieren kann.
Er hat war das hat er dieses executive order geschrieben bevor oder nachdem dieser tweet war mit dem looping stars des shootings starts.
Also ich glaube das war davon auch unabhängig wie das jetzt zeitlich zueinander hängt das weiß ich nicht ganz genau ich vermute mal das war noch davor aber ich weiß nicht sicher.
Muss man glaube ich auch noch kurz benennen also im kontext dieser das war der der zweite schlag den twitter quasi gegen ihn gemacht hat wer.
Über die demonstration anlässlich der ermordung von george floyd schrieb.
Loading start the shootingstars was also bedeutet also wenn die plenderei losgeht dann fangen wir an zu schießen und das ist eine.
Aussage die von.
Die irgendwie aus den neunzehnhundertsiebenundsechzig jahren ja in den auch hier auf rassismus beruhenden gesellschaftlichen auseinandersetzung.
In den usa zurückgeht das war walter.
Harald der in miami zwanzig jahre polizeichef war und der hat quasi auch eben dafür bekannt,
rassistisch agiert zu haben insbesondere sich eben gegen die silvia bewegung hier ausgesprochen zu haben das ist also quasi ein nicht nur ein.
Eine gewaltandrohung sondern eben auch eine,
historisch sehr belastete aussage die eben auf die rassistischen hintergrund zeigt und da hat bitter dann gesagt das ist eine glorifizierung von gewalt
aber wir lassen diese wir lassen diesen tweet stehen.
Weil wir es für ja öffentlich relevant halten dass der präsident der vereinigten staaten so etwas äußert und das hatten die hatte twitter ja schon vor einiger zeit als deren.
Leitlinie herausgegeben dass sie sagten wenn der trump irgendwie hetzt und unwahrheiten verbreitet löschen wir das nicht als.
Wie wir es bei anderen leuten tun würden.
Sondern wir lassen da stehen aber wie wir weil es eben eine besondere historische oder gesellschaftliche person ist politische figur
person des öffentlichen interesses und jetzt haben sie es aber ausgegraut und quasi mit einem warnhinweis versehen gab dann auch irgendwie habe ich auf twitter scott haben wir vorbei jemand der einfach
immer die inhalte von donald trump getwittert.
War nach vierundzwanzig stunden geblockt.
Wurde sofort gelöscht weil wegen hassrede.
Ja
Also täter hat ihn hat ihn quasi zweimal sind sie im in kurzer folge in die in die parade gefahren und das kann natürlich donald trump nicht auf sich sitzen lassen.
Jetzt ist natürlich diese maßnahme ganz interessant weil letzten endes was er hier angedroht hat ist dass
diese dieser ausschluss der haftung von plattformen für die inhalte dass der dadurch ein bisschen ausgehöhlt wird das ist so quasi die die drohung die da drin stehen ich.
Nicht so hundertprozentig verstanden was jetzt hier konkret damit gemacht werden soll und ob das ding auch auch nur behauptet wird er hätte das unterschrieben also ist ja man kann sich aber trump auch nicht sicher sein dass wenn er jetzt sagt er würde jetzt irgendeine x y oder ausgeben
ob er das dann auch wirklich tut oder ob er das nur sagt dass er das tut und dass das irgendwie an sich erstmal nur so eine drohgebärde ist weil es macht natürlich.
Ist auf das ist auf white house goa veröffentlicht am achtundzwanzigsten mai.
Ist es schon ok ja gut.
Beide in mir ist president lala la hierbei geht es hierbei ordert follows.
Ja aber du weißt auch nicht ob dann das justizministerium da auch irgendeiner form irgendwelche aktionen folgen lassen wird so das ist.
Offen glaubt dem einfach gar nichts und ja jetzt die frage was was heißt denn das eigentlich meine das ist ja auch so eine debatte die uns hier auch immer noch so ein wenig in zwei.
Dieses wie gehen wir denn eigentlich mit den plattformen um und wem legen wir denn jetzt hier das schwert in die hand in irgendeiner form.
Maßregeln sensorisch einzugreifen,
wessen aufgabe ist das ist das die aufgabe des staates ist es die aufgabe der leute selbst ist es die leute aufgabe der der plattform wenn es die aufgabe der plattform ist auf basis welcher gesetze was,
was ist hier überhaupt der richtige weg und ich glaube da haben wir auch alle noch keine absolut zufriedenstellende antwort drauf.
Was mich was mich vor allem auch so irritiert ist dass er ja gleichzeitig da eben von haftungsfragen die rede ist und,
eigentlich ist ja quasi die haftungs- befreiung die basis
für die freie rede also der will quasi ein bisschen beides entziehen also es macht nicht so ganz sinn was er was er
also er er gibt an der general sollte sich da jetzt irgendwie halt gedanken drüber machen ja und es ging um die stärkung der freien rede in in den usa dann sagt er möchte gegen zensur einen schutz haben ja
sollen also quasi zensur soll stärker unter strafe gestellt werden für diese plattform.
Dann sagt er protecting federal text papier dollars vom financing online-plattformen restriktiv,
free speach mit anderen worten wenn die ihm nicht gefallen dann dürfen die aus staatlichen mitteln kein geld mehr bekommen ja also will quasi,
komplette staatliche werbung quasi verbieten auf diesen plattformen dann soll es irgendwie fatal eine federal review stattfinden von unfairen
unterdrückungen und also wirklich sehr sehr irre aber du hast recht er sagt der general soll also jetzt
ein legislative framework dafür entwickeln und,
mit anderen worten eine gesetzliche basis soll dann erst entstehen und.
Ist eine drohkulisse so und man muss sich jetzt eben fragen wer ist jetzt hier eigentlich der adressat ist das twitter ja oder ist es nicht eher facebook
bei facebook geht es ja auch gerade wild her weil
zuckerberg sagt er immer so ja ne dann inhalte und so haben wir nichts mit zu tun das ist ja hier freie rede und wir wollen ja nicht die freie rede einschränken weil es ja ein menschenrecht und überhaupt eine auf der basis der,
amerikanischen sichtweise der welt sozusagen total wichtig dass die leute ja sagen können was sie wollen auch wenn es irgendwie hetzerisch ist zeug ist,
und man kann das eben auch alles so deuten als droht senario so nach dem motto ich könnte euch ja das leben schwer machen
wenn ihr nicht so wollt wie ich will das lese ich da eigentlich so ein bisschen,
zwischen den zeilen raus und es mehren signal an facebook als an twitter weil letzten endes ist twitter für trump zwar.
Ein interessanter outlet kanal so ein veröffentlichung medium
aber manipulativ vorgehen kann man halt sehr viel besser auf facebook mit diesen zugeschnitten nachrichten das haben wir ja alles schon im rahmen der wahl hier mehrfach diskutiert und ja
zuckerberg hält sich halt mal wieder raus und
richtig geil finde es viele leute die bei facebook arbeiten nicht so so das ist jetzt auch schon diverse leute gibt die da sich öffentlich geäußert haben und auch schon ihren job gekündigt haben beziehungsweise intern zumindest auch
gegen diese grundhaltung protestieren also auch da brodelt es.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass der also wenn ich das richtig gehört habe.
Hat die trump kampagne schon vor längerer zeit aufgehört irgendwie werbung auf twitter zu schalten.
Was klar ist ne ich meine wenn du da irgendwie fuffzig millionen follower hast oder wie viele der hat dann brauchst du nicht noch werbung zu schalten das ist dann bist du halt premiumkunde und boss braucht nicht zu bezahlen.
Vor allem die dich bitten ja auch die linken alle irgendwie weil sie die ganze zeit hier autrag guck mal was trump wieder geschrieben hat und sollte ich auch meine denke so leute ja verbreitet die scheiße nicht auch noch.
Also ich meine teilweise ja es ist die frage ist willst du es wird es noriega das finde ich kann nämlich kannst nämlich genauso wenig ja also es ist es ist wirklich wir haben einfach muss man ganz ehrlich sagen wir haben einfach,
als.
Demokratische und liberale gesellschaft nicht den umgang mit diesem typen gefunden wir haben einfach nie damit gerechnet dass jemand.
Irgendwann mal so wenig er gefühl hat.
Dass er das tun würde dass das gehen würde bei allen klar aber man hat nicht gedacht dass es jemand durchzieht und dass das auf eine gesellschaft trifft die.
Geht das dann auch toleriert das ist ja das problem.
Genau die das die das ja auf eine weise irgendwie toleriert also ich denke es bitter sollte den trump count einfach schließen fertig.
Und dann lass ihn mal lass ihn mal losgehen dann lasse lasse mal gas geben wollen wir mal schauen.
Lass mal gucken wo er dann veröffentlicht.
Der hat ja seine outlets also der.
Ich finde es immer interessant dass immer seine tweets zitiert werden aber niemals das was er auf facebook schreibt wo ja der ganze kram auch hingeht.
Ja das scheint ja irgendwie daran zu legen dass dass die journalisten alle auf twitter sind ne.
Ja es ist so der der der verlautbarungsorgan kanal und das scheint facebook so nicht zu sein
so du kannst ja auch nicht eben mal eine nachricht auf facebook so ohne weiteres auf die webseite packen und ich sage teilweise einloggen zu müssen wenn ich das richtig sehe also es ist schwierig.
Ja sascha lobo ist ja der meinung wir sind wir beobachten jetzt hier ein staatsstraße in vorbereitung ja dem kann man.
Nicht für ausgeschlossen.
Halte ich auch nicht für ausgeschlossen also darf den charakter hat es eigentlich von anfang an schon gehabt und vielleicht ist start streiche nicht das richtige wort,
aber es ist schon klar dass die republikaner bereit sind alles zu tolerieren
was in irgendeiner form dazu führen könnte dass sie diese wahl nicht verlieren.
Und die haben da einfach jeglichen jegliches maß verloren und das macht jetzt auch nicht davor halt einfach so ein gewalt hagel über die bevölkerung abzuschicken.
Das dann den entsprechenden effekt haben wird
weiß man nicht ich würde auch wahlmanipulation nicht ausschließen werden und sicherlich auch an den gedanken gewöhnen müssen dass eine ähnliche militärische präsenz dann auf einmal zum wahltag auch da ist.
Ja die irgendwas schützen will die dann wahlbüros schützt vor antifa.
Und dann kommen dann kommen halt menschen da einfach gar nicht erst hin deswegen auch dieser aufschrei briefwahl zu verhindern weil damit könnte man bescheißen was
so viel heißt wie damit könnte man ja eine normale wahl durchführen deswegen muss das ja verhindert werden.
Ja spezifisch sagen in den in den usa geht gerade um das wahlrecht das einmal gesagt ist jerry mentoring also das zuschneiden von wahlbezirken so dass ich in diesen wahlbezirken bestimmte mehrheiten ergeben.
Das ist der eine teil und.
Der funktioniert natürlich deshalb weil du eine immer noch sehr stark segregierten gesellschaft hast das heißt du kannst einfach sagen okay die schwarzen bereiche
die teilen wir im prinzip unsere wahlbezirke wir haben da einen schwarzen bezirk,
und jetzt machen wir die wahlbezirke so dass der dieser schwarze anteil viergeteilt wird auf vier andere so dass in diesen vier bezirken wieder eine weiße mehrheit gewinnt.
Und wir quasi diese schwarze minderheit auf verschiedene wahlbezirke aufteilen sodass sie irgendwo eine mehrheit erlangen kann,
einfach erklärt wie man ring funktioniert.
Wer sich damit genauer auseinandergesetzt hat wird das wird ja jetzt sagen dass es eine vereinfachte darstellung ist zweitens die entziehen ja straftätern das wahlrecht.
Was und verurteilen die ganze zeit,
dunkelhäutige menschen als straftäter sodass sie hier eben eine massive benachteiligung der schwarzen.
Bevölkerung haben weil sie die einerseits benachteiligten kriminalisieren und dann von der wahl ausschließen.
Das ist wirklich irre und dann gibt's noch ein phänomen dass in den usa ja eigentlich ja so bekannt ist ne dass man im prinzip sagt er
der der das setting president also der amtsinhaber präsident ist im prinzip gut beraten zum ende seiner ersten amtszeit irgendeine form von krieg zu haben.
Weil üblicherweise in zeiten des krieges oder der krise sich das amerikanische volk hinter den amtsinhaber stellt und nicht einen regierungswechsel.
Herbeiführt das ist irgendwie so eine ja so eine gilt als eine der weisheiten hat bei george bush bestätigung gefunden.
Und ja gewissermaßen ja wenn ich das jetzt richtig erinnere auch bei obama jetzt wird
der trump eigentlich dafür gelobt dass man sagt hey super der hat keine neuen kriege angezählten im gegenteil der hat die der zieht sich aus den alten konflikten zurück und lässt überlässt die leute dort leben
ja dem dem der ungeklärten,
kauft ihr schon anarchie und den bürgerkriegen die sie dann dadurch entfachen und dafür wird eigentlich gelobt meine schlimmste befürchtung ist dass sein krieg einfach ein bürgerkrieg sein wird,
und dass er jetzt quasi bei seinen weißen und evangelikalen
wählen wlan im prinzip halt angst vor der vor bürgerkrieg vor sozialem aufruhr vor den schwarzen schürt.
Und sich dadurch versucht zu stabilisieren und ich glaube leider dass das eine.
Gute strategie ist im sinne von erfolgsversprechend leider muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Und da würde auch reinpassen dass er jetzt irgendwie sagt hier ich will hier ist meine order to in schuhe free speach und jetzt lege ich mich mal mit facebook und twitter an.
Würde mich würde ja gut was für deine trump noch wundern es ist wirklich fürchterlich.
Ja das ist alles ganz furchtbar mein u s a angefangen wieder bei den usa gelandet was haben wir denn noch.
Wir kommen jetzt zu den kurzmeldungen wir müssen ja langsam zum ende kommen mit dieser sendung also es gibt einmal ein ein aufruf der uns aus kanada ereilt von vanessa.
Wir spricht man den namen jetzt aus weiß ich jetzt gerade auf modell rodeln rodeln die im zweifel ist dieser name.
Ein,
eingedeutscht kanadier verengt löscht ist eine der person die edward snowden in den slums von hongkong versteckt hat im juni zwanzig dreizehn.
Und durch unseren freund des hauses robert tipo den menschenrechtsanwälte auch mehrmals schon auf dem c kongress gesprochen hat nun.
Tatsächlich in kanada asyl gefunden hat sie wurde dort von einer ngo unterstützt mit dem namen vor der refugees und diese unterstützung ist jetzt quasi aus und sehe sie braucht quasi,
nun irgendeine form von unterstützung um sich dort in kanada integrieren zu können.
Da gibt's also wieder ein spendenaufruf für verlinken einen bericht über die situation zweitens gibt es eine.
Sammelklage gegen google also eine milliardenklage weil.
Der weil in chrome der inkognito modus nicht vernünftig funktioniert hat.
Also der inkognito modus hat trotzdem tracking durch google erlaubt und nahegelegt dass man jetzt also in cognito im internet sei aber es da eben eine technische.
Bedauerliche technische schwäche gab die google nicht so wirklich kommuniziert hat.
Das hast du davon wenn du die halten browser von google ausgerechnet geben lässt auch dazu verlinken wir
ich bin mal gespannt wie es da weitergeht und dann gibt es von unserem auch eher auch
seit langjährigen freund claudio der ja inzwischen seit einigen jahren bei amnesty international im technology ist der hat sich die
kaputte corinna von katar angeschaut in katar gibt es,
zwang ist also eine zentrale zentrale app alle daten werden zentral und auch nicht passiert oder sonst wie vorgehalten.
Die app ist verpflichtend und sie hat eine integrierte digitale fußfessel funktion und,
auch eine einfache kontrolle nämlich die die stellt dann so einen code da also wenn du irgendwo bist kannst du die zeigen und der ist dann irgendwie rot gelb oder grün je nachdem ob du quasi gerade eine katherine verordnet hast ja.
Und kann dann irgendwie gescannt werden um das contact dressing zu erleichtern was dadurch dass du diese code funktion hast kannst du.
Auch eine zentralisierte app irgendwie mit manuell,
arbeiten lassen tja das ganze ding hat natürlich wenn du den code gänzen dann wird quasi wenn die daten aus dem r code abgefragt und was du dann zurückkriegst sind persönliche daten wie namen in englischer und arabischer notstation.
Und der ort wo du dich aufhalten sollst oder behandelt wirst dein gesundheitssenator,
und irgendwie auch deine wo du halt behandelt oder getestet wurde also radikal direkt einmal persönliche daten gesundheitsdaten und so weiter,
der code der sich in dem querkopf verbirgt ist sogar noch so plump dass sie den relativ einfach gezielt generieren kannst um dich quasi über bestimmte personen zu informieren.
Hat diese schwachstelle gemeldet die wurde behoben aber es ist natürlich trotzdem wieder ein
paradebeispiel ne warum man keine zentralisiertes daten haltung in solchen schnell zu bauenden apps haben möchte das war ja auch eines der zentralen argumente es handelt sich bei so etwas um ein mamutprojekt
unglaublicher basis man geht da in der territory man muss da einfach risiken minimieren so wie es eben jetzt auch in deutschland getan wird.
Also da auch nochmal eine interessante verlinkung und gruß an und dann freund claudia.
Dann gibt es gerade zwei konsultationen auf der eu ebene und ich denke dass wir die beide in einer kommenden sendung sicherlich auch nochmal mit.
Thomas besprechen werden thomas lohn.
Was heißt denn das genau konsultationen.
Ja die und zwar macht die comics kommission veröffentlicht dann so so whitepaper und holt dann mal so ein bisschen.
Meinungen aus der bevölkerung oder aus den interessenvertretungen ein das heißt sie haben ja im prinzip so webseiten wo sie umfragen machen machen wirklich so eine das sind,
kannst du also einen account anlegen unter,
ich glaube europa punkt eu und da gibt's dann eben in diesem ersten fall von dem ich jetzt spreche ein ein kostüm da wird also gesagt wenn wir das jetzt das beispiel von dem ich gerade spreche
im weitesten sinne regulieren wollen was halten sie dabei für wichtig,
ja dann sag's halt so ich bin eine vertreterin der zivilgesellschaft und ich finde für mich ist wichtig dass.
Folgende grenzen für die bestehen und folgende nicht oder so und da geht's eben auch in dieser konsultation.
Das whitepaper und artificial intelligence eben die frage zu gesichtserkennung.
Und da kannst du eben kann man sich quasi einbringen ob und inwiefern gesichtserkennung in verbindung mit ai in europa akzeptabel sein soll oder nicht,
da kann man also dazu rufen insbesondere unsere freunde von der digitalen freiheit auf sich daran zu beteiligen um hier eben auch ne wenn schon.
Auf eu-ebene solche meinungs erfassungen stattfinden dass man sich daran eben auch beteiligt lobbyistinnen und lobbyisten werden es tun vertreterin der zivilgesellschaft können es auch tun
und da wird wird eben darum gebeten sich daran zu beteiligen ich denke gerade so ein europäisches framework für a i ist ist,
deshalb notwendig weil wenn wenn das jetzt in nationale regelungen zerbricht dann hast du wieder diese uneinheitliche zeit dann hast du wieder so ein race the bottom und am ende.
Setzt sich dann der irische nicht standard durch und da denke ich kann man sich auf jeden fall mal dran beteiligen der link zu dieser öffentlichen konsultation ist bei uns in den shownotes.
Genauso gibt es jetzt eine konsultation zur.
Zum digital services das ist im prinzip die revolte hätte ich jetzt fast gedacht die wir nehmen wir das denn.
Der wieder gänger neuauflage.
Revidierung neuauflage der der e-commerce richtlinie wo es eben.
Um diese frage geht die wir gerade auch schon touchiert haben welche rolle plattformen eben bei der vermeidung von fehlinformationen während wahlen oder gesundheitsrisiken spielen wie man also einerseits hassrede,
online eindämmen kann und ein gleichgewicht findet zwischen meinungsfreiheit und ja.
Im schutz der persönlichkeitsrechte ja und eben also gleichzeitig in der ausgestaltung eine,
ein spielraum für innovation im innen im eu binnenmarkt herstellen kann das ist das was thomas hier schon,
sehr regelmäßig angekündigt hat dass es hier das wichtigste ist was uns in diesem jahr begleiten wird diese.
Konsultation läuft bis zum achten september und ja geht's also einmal um.
Wer soll jetzt haftbar sein für creator content ja und wenn da eben eine falsche entscheidung entsteht dann kann das eben massive folgen haben,
für
wie wir das internet kennen zweitens geht es den eben um ein level playing field in european digital markets ja wo sie sagen im prinzip gibt es aktuell ein paar sehr große plattformen die als geld keeper agieren wie kann man da
quasi deren macht gegen balancieren.
Und dann natürlich noch ein bisschen um wettbewerbsrecht ich denke wir werden das lieber nochmal mit thomas hier diskutieren weil es ist ein weites feld wenn ich mich nicht täusche hat er dazu auch,
auf dem sechsunddreißig ein vortrag gehalten er soll ich nochmal raus wir werden es auf jeden fall nochmal.
Behandeln denke ich content takedown clans die internet war das glaube ich.
Ok jedenfalls thema dass wir lieber mit thomas nochmal behandeln weil der sich in diesem ganzen bereich einfach immer sehr viel besser auskennt als ich und deswegen sich das mal an ihn.
Dort thomas hast du gehört ne.
Genau wir aber wir wir nennen schon mal die wir nennen schon mal die die konsultation hier und rufen euch auch hier dazu auf euch daran zu beteiligen.
Wenn das zweifelsfall auch als chaos computer club dann mal versuchen.
Ja das bringt uns zum ende der sendung oder denkt schon weil's auch lange noch.
Aber musste mal sein also diese dieses thema medienkritik ich muss wirklich sagen wie wie sehr ich mich freue dass das jetzt hier von riesa mal aufgegriffen wird das ist wie gesagt,
es ist alles nichts neues für menschen die sich damit jeden tag auseinandersetzen aber umso wichtiger ist es dass er das noch nicht mit seiner reichweite in aus seiner zielgruppen transportiert die vermutlich,
sich in dieser tiefe wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt alles schon mit dem thema auseinandergesetzt haben und deswegen leistet der da wirklich eine denke ich eine sehr wichtige gesellschaftliche.
Arbeit.
Genau er hat auch ein paar in seinem video übrigens auch ein paar andere youtube-kanäle genannt die auch positiv auffallen die kann ich jetzt gerade nicht auswendig aufzählen ich habe.
Einer davon war glaube ich simplicity mus.
Polizistin muss war dabei.
Ein interview gegeben.
Kurz gesagt und so weiter also
auch ein paar ganz gute links kann man sich auf jeden fall auch nochmal anschauen also es gibt schon einiges aber es kann auf jeden fall auch noch mehr werden ich würde mich freuen wenn's weniger um
das gesamte gesellschaftliche drumrum ginge und vielleicht mal mehr um die gesellschaft als solche das könnte dieses jahr auch ganz gut gebrauchen.
Und unsere nerven auch und überhaupt langweilt das manchmal auch immer an die einzigen zu sein will uns nicht einfach mal jemanden bisschen aus dem business nehmen das wäre doch mal was.
Oder so eine entwicklung politik braucht es eigentlich gar nicht mehr weil wir wollen wir noch erzählen.
Ich wäre jetzt rufst du jetzt dazu auf uns auf youtube zu ersetzen oder oder was meinst du.
Nicht auf youtube und zu ersetzen sondern einfach uns uns uns die die geschäftsgrundlage zu entziehen durch eine positive gesellschaftliche entwicklung dass wir dann auch youtube kanäle aufmachen können und uns über schminktipps und so weiter ausbreiten können.
Ja also ich ich ich fordere oder ich.
Wie macht man die original linus neumann tolle richtig ja das ist einfach mal so so so so fragen die leute eigentlich bewegen und die ganze zeit abgelenkt werden durch diese ganzen politischen zerrüttet.
Ich möchte ich möchte in einer welt leben in der wir nur noch als system stabilisierende jubel perser des status quo wahrgenommen werden.
Jetzt kommt wieder logbuch netzpolitik und applaudiert der regierung.
Ja genau so und dann dann stehen wir da und sagen einfach das ist das geheimnis warum wir immer so jung geblieben sind.
Ja das das das möchte ich ja das wäre schön.
Das hätten wir gerne.
So gern ich möchte teil einer jubel perser bewegung sein aber man lässt mich halt es gibt halt.
Lässt es halt nicht genau also bringt uns entweder entweder ruiniert unsere geschäftsgrundlage und solange das nicht geht weiter spenden.
Leute macht's gut bis bald.
Spaß im internet lasst euch nicht ärgern.